so with everything we learned about Elon
Musk and Twitter this FBI guy that was
basically planted or embedded in
whatever you want to call it we now have
three investigations into Elon Musk and
his companies and San Francisco is now
saying they're going to be looking into
the fact that there are beds in the
Twitter headquarters okay it may sound
like a stupid story but the retaliations
here you don't get to expose the FBI and
government corruption without them
trying to do something back but I must
say my friends this is a white pill
moment you know they're struggling to do
anything to stop the dam breaking the
funny thing about this this beds
investigation you got these woke
medialis and corporate press being like
Elon actually is having employees sleep
in the office oh how could he
go back a few years every big tech
office bragging about how they have beds
and nap time in their buildings Elon
isn't doing anything special but of
course they will spin it and they will
manipulate it so we'll talk about that
plus we got AOC she's being investigated
she's going to be investigated by the
ethics uh committee I believe she's
being investigated for ethics violations
I think it was having to do with uh
receiving a very very expensive Met Gala
tickets you know they want to make sure
that the capital city and Hunger Games
that certain people are allowed in so
that they can maintain their power
structure so we'll talk about that too
plus joining us today we have Shane
Cashman who uh I'll give you the quick
version before we get in everything
after yay stormed out of the uh the
interview
Shane actually talked to him got invited
out to embed with him and then did and
the stories pretty crazy so uh we'll get
into that a little bit I think the the
insights into what's going on this
campaign campaign not particularly
particularly interesting as I think it
was Jack pesobic who reported that yay
has updated his FEC filings for his 2024
run which is apparently going to be
happening so I guess we'll expect to see
some more of this before we get started
my friends head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com and pick up a
virtual Shield download it's a virtual
private network service which is a basic
layer of security for you as you browse
the web if you're worried about
government hackers or just nosy
individuals corporations trying to spy
on you a virtual private network is a
good way to do it and virtual Shield
they're our first sponsor ever going
back years so don't give money to people
who hate who hate you give your money to
companies that support the work we're
doing by going to
surfinginternetsafe.com they say their
VPN service is compatible with all
devices it allows you to browse the web
safely securely and anonymously using
their Global Network of private IPS it
lets you browse the web anonymously so
the big name isps and other third
parties will not be able to Monitor and
sell your internet activity using their
VPN VPN service your traffic is routed
through their secure and encrypted
servers meaning that any censorship or
restrictions by are bypassed uh any any
restrictions on your internet
it's fast it's reliable completely free
for 30 days available on everything Mac
Windows iPhone iPad Android Chrome does
all the work for you download you press
go you're good to go personal family and
business plans available family plans
includes 15 devices business plans allow
you to add as many employees as you want
and it will completely encrypt your
Wi-Fi connection too so it'll block
Hackers from trying to get access to
your devices when you're when you're
doing your thing again surfing
internetsafe.com shout out to Virtual
Shield thank you so much for sponsoring
us and supporting the show and also
don't forget to go to timcast.com become
a member we have a members only show
coming up for you tonight uncensored not
so family friendly I imagine this one
will be a whole lot of fun we got a lot
of stuff to talk about joining us today
uh smash the like button subscribe to
the channel share the show with your
friends there you go joining us today is
Mr Bryson gray yeah what are you in the
building we finally here that's right
what's Poppin G this is our third
attempt at having a wrap around
I'm not gonna walk out bro I'm not gonna
walk out just don't Smack the mic don't
walk out we gotta at least get one we
need one I got 2G we out here let's go
right on so do you want to give a brief
introduction to what you're doing oh
yeah um I am bigot of the year I am the
most homophobic person of all time I can
make Christian conservative rapper uh
Bryson great man I picked guy Ferris Guy
family country that's what I care about
I'm a bible thumper too you know just
trying to glorify God through music and
change culture because without culture
nothing else changes right on and as I
mentioned we have Shane Cashman who uh
aside from running Tales from the
inverted World on timcast.com you
actually were just hanging out with yay
for quite a bit yeah I haven't slept in
like a week like since meeting him it
was such a crazy ride to even get out
there and um it was a great weekend a
very positive exciting uh insight into
his campaign and everything he's doing I
have to imagine as you're waiting aboard
the plane and he's ranting about
praising Hitler you were probably a
little worried that happened on the way
to the airport and everyone's hitting me
up they're like this is it jump ship and
I'm like I still see positivity here I
refuse I'm like psychotically optimistic
so I I was doing and then he started
like talking smacking on you I'm like oh
this is gonna be even crazier I'm like
how am I getting on this plane but I was
like I gotta do it it's it's too
important and there's too many
interesting things to me and I'm a
massive fan of his so it was uh the last
one apparently yeah well I got that
phone call and they were like one this
one friend who was one of the only other
people I was like this guy is rolling
with yay forever and he was out and he
called me the last EA fan on Earth I'm
like
I guess but um yeah I got in the plane
and I had a really uh exciting awesome
weekend and the story's now live on
timcast.com so check it out right on
Luke's here so yeah we are oh for two
with rappers so good luck Bryson uh my
name is Luke kardowski here of we are
change.org and today I'm wearing a
t-shirt that I think is important
because it's related to a lot of adult
content that is free out there I think
it's free for a reason there have been
governments that used it before as a
form of warfare against populations and
that's why I created the shirt that I'm
wearing right now with one of the most
prominent popular adult website logos
but instead of the actual words it says
mind control and if you like the shirt
you like the messaging you could support
me by getting the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do that's why I'm here search high
energy how are you hey what's up YouTube
high energy today it's gonna be a good
one
um so far let's go all right well ladies
and gentlemen we have we had big news
this morning big news yesterday Elon
Musk outed this FBI agent who was uh
former disgraced FBI agency or he is a
former FBI agent and disgraced
he becomes Deputy general counsel at
Twitter Elon Musk boots him out
we have this tweet from John Hassan he
says in the last two months the feds
have launched investigations into
neuralink Twitter and Tesla sure seems
like Elon Musk is being targeted this is
a good news right we may be we may be
looking at some really bad stuff
happening Elon the big story from this
morning I guess Elon musk's tweet
confirms he's added staff beds at
Twitter HQ but insists he's just helping
tired employees framing it like this big
negative thing and now we're hearing
that SF is actually going to be
investigating as if he's you know
mistreating his employees or something
this is a good news you know why the
fact that we can see how obvious and
Brazen it is it didn't used to be this
way they used to be able to get away
with this stuff control smash destroy
they would character assassinate or you
know maybe even actually assassinate
people and now they're struggling to
even go after one dude who bought a
social media Network I I I get it he's
the richest guy in the world or was and
he bought Twitter which was one of the
biggest social media platforms so he's
not just a guy but they're struggling to
get it done they can't go after him so
you know this morning I was talking
about or earlier today
we got all this crime we got uh you know
California shutting down their third
prison they're just releasing everybody
and all this stuff sounds really really
bad but I actually think we should look
at it in a positive light the system is
is breaking down the corrupt people are
failing California crime is through the
roof they can't figure out they're
getting everything's getting worse the
FBI the feds they want to go after Elon
Musk they're failing he just gutted the
collusion between big Tech and social
media so I'm feeling pretty good what
about you guys I I like what he's doing
with Twitter and everything but I'm not
gonna lie
um he gives me Revelation 13 Vibes so if
they investigate nerd link shut it down
some type of way and they are doing this
just to attack Elon Musk but listen man
I watched Elon Musk interviews for years
this man literally said he wants
everybody to have access to any
information with just a thought you know
he said he said it's we can't beat AI so
he wants us wants us to combine with it
and now he's you know promoting that it
could fix a lot of diseases that sounds
like great wonders and if you read
Revelation 13 then it just fits it but
everything else is gay so you're not a
fan of the microchip you're not going to
be implantica in your head and having
the mark of the beast inside of there no
sir I did a documentary advice and uh
the the girl she showed me her chip and
she did it and like you can see it in
there and I was like Wow demonic I said
it to her too you remember when Alex
Jones was talking about this 15 years
ago yeah and he was like people listen
they're going to put chips in you you're
gonna do your chips and I was watching
that this is back in like 2008 or
something and I was like this guy's
crazy like prisonplanet.tv or whatever
the website was back in the day I was
there screaming with him yeah Vera chip
I think and then there were like videos
of people and they put their hand up to
the door and stuff like that they really
tried to do that again during covet
nobody wanted to do it now you mean to
tell me you couldn't get people to put a
little a little thing in their hand to
open doors and pay and you think that
they're going to take a computer chip
and put it in their brain
I think we're close to a future where
parents are going to have to fight with
their kids about becoming Immortal or
not you know their kids are gonna be
like I want to put it in my brain and
upload my Consciousness onto a computer
and I'm gonna have to be like no you
can't well and they're going to be mad
about me for saying no Tim we also have
to understand you know it's not that a
lot of people are going to be willingly
doing this it's that a lot of people are
going to be forced to do this whether
they like it or not to comply with the
larger social credit score and even
though it didn't work before with a lot
of fear-mongering surrounding global
warming even though it didn't work with
covid right now I think the next step
the next level of what they're going to
try to do is to crash the economy and
use that in order to push in a central
bank digital currency then that's going
to bring in the social credit score then
that's going to bring in the total
totalitarian system that they've been
testing in China and are going to
introduce everywhere around the world
base Luke I think covet covet also
ushered in these people being more
willing to put chips in their brain with
like everyone's digital identities you
know you mean more to them I think a lot
of people will sign up actually you're
right man I'm gonna walk that statement
back about people not wanting to bring
chips um that's that's too like Echo
chamber insular you take a look at
what's going on in these cities man I'd
be willing to bet people would shove
stuff right up their ass like if the
government told them to do it no the
girl I mean there's there's a video
we'll get to in a minute where a guy's
wearing a mask and someone not wearing a
mask walks past him the guy freaks out
and starts trying to fight the guy like
I'm telling you man I I go to this I was
in Frederick Maryland the other day and
I'm seeing people wearing masks and it's
and it's it's scary it like it actually
creeps me out like yo what are you doing
do you eat here listen listen the
science has changed okay the science has
changed they're they're coming out now
there's a bunch of arguments about masks
being ineffective and all that stuff but
there are still people wearing 57 masks
all over their bodies but Tim what you
mentioned I just want to quickly
interject here especially what your
previous point about injecting stuff up
the you know what that the butt is that
is a family-friendly show here that is
already happening in China with the
swabs that they're using in order to
test individuals with that they violated
the U.S uh um U.S embassy employees with
that I just saw a horrible video where
they just took an old lady and they just
forced one of those swabs in there as
well
that's what they're doing in China
the U.S consulate was complaining about
U.S embassy workers being forcefully and
violently tested in China or covid up
there you know what we were talking
about this last year I was screaming
about this I was like I was I was
foretelling this for many years to come
and it is here now there's a reason they
have U.S military members walk around in
heels okay this is a slow
loyal to some a lot of crazy nonsense
did you guys see the the guy who said he
was retiring and he was wearing the dog
mask or whatever yeah yeah but I just
want to point out real quick I want you
to imagine that you're like walking down
the street in New York in 2015 and
Luke's holding a big sign being like the
butt swaps are coming they're gonna
shove it up here but they are and
they're doing that right now in China
they're testing it in China they're like
let's see what we could get away with in
China oh the U.S embassy the embassy is
here let's test it on on them they were
complaining about how bad it hurts
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no not wiping
people who see the future like that or
like Alex like they always sound insane
to everyone living in like the now but
reality is collapsed clearly like we're
not defining it as how we should be like
the world is done I'm sorry well that's
why I'm laughing you know it looks like
you're laughing but it's happening I
know we're laughing it's um it's the the
kicker guard thing the cloud comes out
on the stage and says there's a fire
broke out and everyone starts laughing
and clapping and then it gets frantic
and panic's not saying no no there's
actually a fire that everyone claps and
cheers and uh that's happening right now
he said I think that's how the world
will end we're the clowns oh you know
you know yeah in the world people will
make memes about it if they feel like a
big bomb coming they'll be like a
hundred memes on Twitter in seconds did
you see that know that there's a meme
where it's like uh it's a
post-apocalyptic City and there's two
guys sitting in the rubble and one guy
hands a picture to the other guy and
it's a meme like just yeah we're there
you gotta keep it going you know you
gotta you gotta try to laugh a little
bit Yeah so so look though Luke you
bring up a really good point uh
I look at everything that's going on
with people mindlessly zombie about I
was a story I told the other day
during during lockdown like a year and a
half ago or whatever I went to a sushi
restaurant with my girlfriend in
Frederick and we walked in and it's very
small like these are small old buildings
and I was probably about 10 feet away
from a chair and they like you got to
put a mask on if you want to come in
nobody anywhere is wearing a mask
wearing because they're eating and they
they told us that we had to leave if we
didn't wear them and I'm just like
complying with this level of psychosis
let's let's bring it back to Elon Musk
yeah the government's going to come out
and they're going to say if you want to
fly you got to get your your real neural
link ID and then they're going to be
like just get it they'll have to start
with something simple right it'll be
something on your phone it'll be like if
you don't have a phone we'll give you
one right now you can get Android phones
for like 20 bucks like really really
cheap they're low end but they work so
they'll be like if you don't have one
then you can apply and we'll give you
one and then you got to have this thing
on it then they're going to give you
some kind of like EEG sensor thing to
wear to like do like an EEG bio check
then eventually they're going to be like
if you want the upgrade and you want to
fly first class for free then you got to
get the direct implant it's like the
people who sign up for car insurance
that allow the insurance company to like
gauge how you're doing right it's like
they have an insight and they can mess
with like your your rates and stuff
through that yeah yeah next level they
put a computer chip in your car and they
track your movement make sure you're not
speeding make sure you're stopping at
stop signs watch every single movie they
make it sound good and now the next
level of that is Tesla insurance with
cameras that are looking inside of you
as you're driving making sure looking
inside side of the vehicle as you're
driving making sure that of course you
are not abusing the the cell phone but
they can turn your car off yeah based on
what we were just talking about you got
to clarify what you mean by camera
inside of you
that's true was it four inches in
Teslas the details here matter
so yeah uh I got Tesla insurance and my
rates went down because I'm a good
driver and because the car drives itself
so it's like you know you get in the car
you press the button and then you just
sit there and the car just drives itself
you gotta worry but here's the crazy
thing there's a camera pointed at you
while you're driving and if you look at
like if you try to change the music it
goes like and it says like pay attention
to the road no no yeah
it's not as intrusive as other companies
other country other companies are a
little bit more intrusive where they
watch your eyes where they watch your
face to make sure it's always focused on
the road uh and then they take away the
special abilities if you don't comply
with it so I think Ford is already doing
this and I think Mustang is already
doing this as well someone correct me if
I'm wrong here because I'm just going
off what I read a couple months ago but
this is technology out there that's even
beyond what Tesla has well Tesla if you
if you don't keep your eyes on the road
it will disable auto drive what yeah I
thought it was just your hands and the
and pressure someone hack a Tesla oh
yeah but these latest Tesla yeah of
course you could you could hack anything
why do you have one you just gave
everyone the idea now who did it
you think the CIA didn't have the
technology
you got a car yes is it is it is it
after is it a 2010 or older yeah your
car can be remote controlled oh
yeah no not my Kia Soul I got a 2013 Kia
Soul my G uh I think anything after 2010
can be fully remote controlled what and
now they're passing regulations where
you can't go over a certain speed limit
in Europe where they have black boxes
where they listen to everything watch
everything uh and we'll be be able to
take full control of your car in Europe
that's some of the legislation that
they're passing over there essentially
allowing the government to hack and
control every aspect of your Driving
Experience so we're sitting here being
like how dare they go after Elon Musk oh
also he's doing really crazy scary stuff
but it's not just him it's it's a lot of
other people in the industry so even
with this neural link thing um there
might be a possibility where he gets
shut down and then Google and alphabet
and the Pentagon come in and then
they're like we got the newer microchip
it's a lot better and there's no one
that's going to stop us because we're
going to have the Monopoly on this as we
just stopped Elon Musk so there's
there's an argument here that I've been
going back and forth on uh that I've
been talking about for a very long time
is that Elon Musk has a lot of power and
a lot of response possibility and when
it comes to that power and
responsibility we want to specifically
know if he's going to be using that
power and responsibility in a good way
or in a bad way because that's a lot of
power for one individual to have is he
doing it so these new powers this new
technology is going to be used for the
greater good or is that greater good
just going to ruin him and destroy him
because it's too much power for one
single person to have that's a question
that I've been going back and forth on I
don't know what do you think well hold
on I just figured it out I'm just gonna
hate everyone because Elon Musk I mean
what if he's like the Pied Piper acting
like we're we you know he's doing all
this good for us I got free speech for
you right here and then basically
there's a box that says free speech and
there's a stick and everybody's running
over doing he's going to pull that stick
and the box is going to come down you
know what I mean that is what's
happening in my opinion and I'm gonna
tell you why I've been in this movement
for a while two years ago conservatives
would have never defended this chip at
all I remember I used to talk about it
now if you look though if you talk about
the Elon Musk chip on on Twitter
conservatives will defend it now it's
like yo yo we actually love it and I
don't think he can use it for good
because he's a Godless Soul right and he
already told you why he's doing it it's
not for the greater good he said we
can't win against AI so we need to
combine with AI he told you this on The
Joe Rogan interview clear-cut well AI is
going to be the next people don't
understand the significance of
artificial intelligence uh Vladimir
Putin has called it uh the next nuclear
weapon and the country that develops it
first will have uh ultimate uh potential
to have total world to domination with
it so when it comes to this power who
would you rather have this latest
technology this is the question that I
think maybe uh some uh Elon Musk Fanboys
are asking themselves do you want China
to have that power do you want alphabets
to have that power or Google the
Pentagon or do you want Elon Musk who is
representing the larger ideas of Free
Speech but at the same time if you're
doing that you shouldn't be wearing a
Satan costume that's worth uh nine
thousand dollars and still have it as
your main profile picture on Twitter
who's to say that he's who's to say that
Google won't create a better version
while he has it yeah you know what I'm
saying like they're going to get or if
he builds it they take it over and
hijack that technology for their own
personal benefit but but the argument is
they're building the technology anyway
it's going to be here anyway uh who's
going to be navigating it is the is the
kind of conversation that I think is
being had here he has said like he's
tried talking to Congress about the
dangers of AI while also
you know creating things that I think
are wildly dangerous that sever you from
humanity and God and I think the chip is
bad
um and I don't agree with it and then I
like obviously I like what he's doing
with Twitter but even with that he's
kind of leading with subjectivity you
know he's basing his emotions on Alex
Jones or yay like on his own personal
feelings and I'm just like you I think
you should be able to say whatever you
want of course but at least he's being
honest about it he's not heard about it
you won't see Google doing that you
don't have the alphabet and that's why
he's better than the alphabet people but
it was like a child right yeah
absolutely
he said he said he banned Kanye because
uh inciting violence yeah it made me
want to punch Kanye so that's why I
banned him yeah he's like who's being
violent now yeah you know what I'm
saying come on I had this uh this Vision
we were it was like one day we were
doing the after show and I had this idea
for like a TV show and it's basically
I'll try and give you the quick synopsis
there's one city left on Earth the
entire planet is basically wiped out
there's just like abandoned cities
everywhere and there's it's it's like 20
80 or something there's a few million
people living in this big city it's the
last City and they have like scouting
missions going out and Gathering old
technology and stuff when one day they
come across these creepy slim looking
humanoid creatures with chrome helmets
who just like blast them with an energy
wave and kill their scouting party but
one guy escapes the long story short of
it is
the people don't understand why the
world ended the news records just ceases
they're looking at old data centers and
they're like trying to go online and
find records and newspapers and around
like you know a certain period or maybe
it's like 21 something a certain period
like in 2070s news just starts to slowly
stop but there's no definitive end
there's no warning there's no war just
one day they're like the record just
slowly trickles off and stops
so the general idea is what would happen
if neurolink became the thing today
and everyone started using it the
conversation would be happening on
norlink more and more and more and if
you weren't using it you would have no
access to the latest news you wouldn't
be in the network
so then a hundred years later the people
who refused call it you know Godless or
evil or satanic or whatever they're like
we don't know what happened just one day
like everybody was gone we can't like
you know if you're like third or fourth
generation down you're like the people
all left we don't know where they went
there's no records of history but then
those creepy creatures I mentioned are
the people who are living in pods
underground wired in the neural link who
come up periodically to collect
resources so that was that was my idea
kind of like it's basically like a
division of what may happen that's like
the evolved version of people deleting
friends off you know different social
media platforms you know you enter these
little Bubbles and then when you see
them again like two years have passed
and politics have passed and there have
all these new ideas they look like
creatures to you everything's different
no I just mean like
the people who use neuralink will become
will be having a conversation you won't
be able to see or hear because you don't
have norling give that 100 years and
what's that going to be it's going to be
like two different species just outright
it will be Eli must say it he wants
everybody to have access to any
information with nerdling that's what he
said he wanted from it out of his own
mouth so what you're saying is like I
mean you might call it a Daydreamer song
but that sounds like what 50 years in my
opinion something like that well who
knows with how fast technology is
advancing and he also said he could have
a microchip already in his brain and no
one would be able to even know that he
has it so that's what he said publicly
as well I think he does
I would love to talk to him about
transhumanism artificial intelligence I
think he knows a lot more than he's
letting on to but his words warning
people about AI I think is very
important that we should be paying
attention it is have you guys have you
guys seen that Viral chat GPT thing the
open AI released this chat bot man it's
crazy
homework is gone there's no such thing
as homework anymore so if you're a
teacher and you tell a kid right write
an essay about you know the pilgrims
landing and what happened you open up
chat GPT and you say write an essay
about the pilgrims Landing in Plymouth
Rock and it will generate a unique essay
boom just like that and then you click
print and you go here you go all done
so this this this chat AI somebody did
something funny where they were like uh
they were like write a joke about George
Floyd in the style of Jerry Seinfeld and
it was just really really bad they were
like well you know the funny thing is
they said it wasn't funny but I think it
was because they were awoke person they
didn't find it funny because it wasn't
funny in the way you'd expect a joke to
be funny but it was kind of funny this
robot trying to mock the death like it
was it's like dark it's like black humor
like very brutal
but uh this AI stuff someone put the
political typology quiz to it like they
asked these questions and the AI was a
liberal one degree to the right of a
progressive leftist so like actually
kind of far left the AIS that are all
being trained are being trained by a
censored far left internet so the future
if conservatives resist all of this and
the left accepts all of this it's gonna
be like some weird sci-fi movie where
you got like some dude in camo Gear with
like black paint under his eyes like an
AR fighting some weird dude flying
through the air shooting lasers at him
me I'm Rambo man let's get it I'm ready
I like I like the war Bryson versus
Robocop you feel me let's get it
guaranteed but I think I think people
are gonna adopt you know earlier on
saying like who's going to want to get a
chip in their brain uh I think you made
it you know a good point when you're
talking about the lockdowns and how
everyone just marches along and now I'm
just like yep you know what it's just
gonna happen I'm gonna go I I agree with
that still but I also want to say like
and this might be like a con attacked
high from the positivity from Yan this
weekend but like
in California every driver I had I had
long conversations with all of them they
were all anti-lockdown anti-like the
government overreach and I was shocked
you know because it really blew my brain
you know because the news I've never
been out there and they make you think
it's a wasteland I think a lot of places
are Wasteland in this country right now
after the last two years but they were
so positive and they saw like a hope
after learning like they saw the
government destroy so many things so
like I did take away some positivity
from those you know it's a handful of
conversations but I didn't expect to
have those so maybe maybe there's a
little bit of Hope out there well I
think most people are still like
conservatives if there's a fair Battle
of ideas conservatives always win you
can see that with Andrew Tate right they
had the band entertain it became the
most popular person in the world fairly
fairly quickly to the point where he
went against the Hassan Packers who
against all these people and he won the
Battle of ideas to the point to where
they had to say you're out of here so if
there's a fair Battle of ideas we still
win because we have so so here's the
crazy thing why if the ideas they have
lose
why do they want them to be maintained
they like power yeah no I get that but
why not just if you why not just adopt
the good idea and maintain power then
they don't think there's a good well I
mean it's not gonna be friction and
Humanity that's as natural as Humanity
as as eating and drinking water right it
doesn't have to be friction so I think
they I mean they they want their ideas
to win I I can be honest right this
might sound crazy I think a lot of these
kids
were put on these pills when they were
younger and they grow up and they don't
understand they they don't understand no
I was at a Matt Walsh rally and I saw a
guy with green hair spit on a a guy that
was on our side and I'm like
do you know what happened where I'm from
you spit on somebody
oh yeah like but but I don't think
people understand they get put on these
pills these pills literally tell you
they make you crazy right and I don't
think they can that's why they can't
function if somebody disagrees with them
right right that's why they can't just
function so I think these are the people
in charge of Twitter not anymore and
charging social media in charge of
everything and and what's going to
happen is there's going to be this ad
campaign from neural link where it's
like only racists don't get me a link
and they're gonna go I'm not a racist
plug me in maybe just they're gonna have
like a thing that's gonna go into your
spinal
literally you could be an oppressed
minority in the AI digital system if you
get the brain chip I see that coming
like you could be Native American
Elizabeth Warren signing up right now
yes I mean I didn't live my life and
then you won't be able to buy or sale
with it I couldn't see I couldn't see
the the shift from Elon Musk you know
neural link playing woke could trying to
be able to sign up that's why I'm like
is he this Pied Piper who's trying to
convince all these people on the right
think about it this way what group of
people will reject neuralink outright
okay it's conservatives they we they go
on shows and they'll outright say like
I'm never getting that I mean you're
saying it right now so Elon Musk knows I
don't need the one over the left they're
gonna do it they're gonna do whatever
they're told to do the right is gonna
resist I need to win them over and then
he's gonna come he'll come out and I
don't know exactly what he'll do to try
and convince people to get norlink he'll
say something like we've had people
defending it and and Fair Point people
who are paralyzed and stuff you know
that really can't help them but I
wouldn't be surprised if he comes out
and he's like you know we're going to
have absolute free speech and we're
going to bypass the system and push back
and boot out the FBI deep State and
we're gonna do it on neuralink we're
going to progress ourselves out of
existence like that's what's happening
and uh I don't like that future
I think it's it's a very Bleak future
one one generation at a time slowly more
and more machine yeah and then in a
thousand years there's no humans there's
just weird robots flying around making
more of themselves but isn't that the
way they convince people because all you
have to do in immediate deserts all the
time and it left all the they're the
best at it you control people with
emotions right if somebody's emotionally
attached to something you you have a
better chance of convincing them so if
neuralink like you already said oh can
help somebody in a wheelchair or a Elon
Musk that can help you if you're blind
it can help you if you have Alzheimer's
you know what I'm saying everybody knows
somebody in their family with these
things you know what I'm saying so if
they pulling your emotional strings I
think a lot of people start getting it
for their family and then next thing you
know nothing that was normalizing
everybody not just that but if you're
depressed if you're anxious which a lot
of people are because of how the diet
has been essentially destroyed here in
the United States which more and more
people are becoming as they're becoming
dependent on big Pharma uh just to
normalize their hormone levels and
endocrine system they have been fried
emotionally and and I think there's a
reason that this is how happening I
think this is all deliberate I think
this is all a part of their agenda
because when you're sad when you're
pathetic you need someone else to step
into your life and then take control of
it that person stepping is is the
government and that government needs and
relies on those people who are destroyed
essentially by them as well and look at
what's happening in Canada with maid
it's like the opposite version but but
just as dark you know sign up you know
fill out an application take your uh
take your life away I mean and for for
simple reasons like that too it's it's
really uh that that terrifies me you got
the same thing you guys ever seen the
movie Gamer with um what's that guys
what's that guy's name uh sounds
familiar well Gerard Butler's in it so
basically there's a guy he's like
falsely accused or something and then
you if you you're on death row you can
you're granted freedom if you elect to
be used as an avatar in a game where
game video Gamers can control your body
and so Gerard Butler is in like this
battlefield he's got to kill people
whatever and this kid's controlling him
he's like okay give me control you've
never seen this no I haven't either and
so who's this oh 10 years ago and so dry
Butler is like give me control and I'll
win and so then the kid like stops and
then Gerard Butler just goes ape and
starts taking everybody out but then
basically the the point of the story is
they have these uh online games where
you can take some kind of like brain
implant that you like snort or something
and then give up control of your body to
someone for someone to use as an avatar
so there's like people who who go to
this club scene and then people use
their bodies for like weird sex stuff
and then in the end what happens is the
guy who made it all has absolute control
over everyone else who's plugged in so
there's like the scene where he's like
doing this weird movement and all the
guys around him are doing the same thing
like he's puppeteering them that's the
thing about neuralink why I'm like I
would love the uh the idea of being able
to plug your brain and like you're
transported into an actual Skyrim like
you see an experience throwing Fireballs
at a dragon or something but what's
gonna happen is elon's gonna knock on
your door and you're going to be like oh
uh Elon Musk is gonna go turn around go
make me a pizza and you go yes you're
gonna turn around he's gonna go do it
and then you're gonna be sitting there
you're going to go you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna be
making the pizza going why am I making a
pizza for him it feels so good I love
doing this why would it it's like yo
when they have norlink in your brain
they're going to come to you and they're
going to say inject this into your blood
they're gonna say hand your kid over and
and you're gonna basically orgasm when
you do these things you hate they will
get you to do things you hate and it
will feel good thousands of orgasms in
your pod as you're being force-fed bugs
uh is essentially the future that allows
you just sold it to some people out
there exactly
that's literally what they're going to
be doing that's how they're going to be
getting that's how they're going to
destroy Humanity with pleasure so you
know I think it's going to be a mix
though of a 1984 style totalitarian
government with of course a Soma Brave
New World reality that I think is also
going to be prevalent as well and we're
seeing this left and right kind of
dichotomy being pushed back and forth
and this is the kind of lock steps that
are being put into place uh acquiescing
Society to towards towards total slavery
here's how it's going to happen
from the Sacramento Bee California moved
to shut down a third state prison as
inmate population shrinks oh the inmate
population is shrinking is that because
people aren't committing crimes anymore
heck no
California there's not enough right
Wingers in California to be prosecuted
so yeah right so uh long story short
they're letting people out they're not
Prosecuting crimes anymore we're seeing
video after video after video of people
writing stores and that's why there's no
one in these in these in these uh
prisons so this is going to lead to just
a further and further collapse so just a
moment ago we're talking about like
norlink and why people are going to want
to plug their brains in there's two
potentials they'll say hey you know what
crime is a serious problem but we don't
want prisons right that's what the left
says how about we give people a brain a
neural link that disables criminal
Behavior oh didn't they also say they
could put people in neural link and put
them in prison for like a hundred years
or something so they could experience
100 years wow that was a movie no no no
no that wasn't but there are also some
conversations we're actually having that
conversation like that could be the
future of Prisons oh man you go insane
yeah it would be like the blink of an
eye but for you it's 100 years you'd
come out just go
like solitary can find for 100 years and
you can't die you can't hurt yourself
like yeah that's torture it's beyond
torture it's crazy that's like sending
someone to Hell literally yeah literally
100 years which is the goal anyway well
sure so what so what's happening now
California shutting down a prison here
we go let me show you this video
is from our good friends of our clown
world let's take a look they're just
wear that I think they're at an Adidas
store and they're just grabbing big
mounds of clothes and they're just
walking out with it gotta have the mask
on though so you don't catch Kobe
welcome in the crown well I mean exactly
why the masses are there right we don't
have to worry about the authorities hold
on like just because you're stealing
something doesn't mean you want to get
sick that's so true someone could sneeze
on you and I know some people out there
are like dude they're wearing masks they
don't get caught get caught they're
shutting down the prisons they're not
worried about getting caught well did it
under 900. yeah yeah it's all good no
worries it's like 980 or something right
yeah something like that I don't know so
I don't know I don't know man look I
don't live in these cities yeah I moved
out is that a good thing or a bad thing
that people are fleeing these places
good
um right now they're also talking about
uh giving people reparations in
California to the tune of I think nearly
600 uh billion dollars uh someone needs
to fact check me that but I heard that
but that's that's again it's just
absolutely absurd where you have George
Soros coming in setting up this these
District Attorneys and letting things go
to chaos uh this chaos I think is
deliberate I think that the major theme
of Robocop is kind of repeating itself
uh if you haven't seen the first movie
and you don't know what that movie's
about definitely just look at this
synopsis of it and it will read like a
history lesson of what's actually
happening right now in all the major
cities it happened in Detroit Detroit's
uh been ravished been destroyed by a lot
of very powerful people and I think it's
happening everywhere else like in New
York City Los Angeles and and uh your
town soon if it's big enough I got an
idea tell me what you guys think
Universal basic income right we give
everybody 1500 bucks a month hear me out
hear me out all right I see you not in
Bryson but but go on but the moment you
accept the program you are disqualified
from voting interesting based I am now
with it you be having people like that
get them out of here let's get you know
well look like it's like a choice no
one's forcing us to vote they're just
saying like look we will we will we'll
take we'll give you some money you know
you can live and do your thing with it
you don't gotta you don't gotta work
you'll have this money you can buy food
and uh you can't vote
well Elon Musk has advocated for Ubi
yeah because he thinks uh ai's gonna
take over but wait a minute so did yay
yay did as well yeah he's calling for a
Ubi as well what for real yep yeah I
didn't even hear that I gotta talk I
gotta talk I gotta talk hey I gotta
style to you because nah we ain't doing
Ubi cuz come on bro and sustainable
government housing all you're doing is
incentivizing people to be lazy and not
want anything sure sure but you don't
get to vote oh no no if you add if you
toss that aspect in there now we talking
about something see right right right so
uh we could we could we could actually
do it it doesn't have to be Ubi it could
be any government program right if you
are accepting funds from the government
in any capacity you can't vote then
after you terminate that assistance and
then for any reason there's like a 30 to
60 day wait before you can re-register
to vote
I think people would be on board with
that and I think that actually solved a
lot of problems for real now the left
would be like what that's not fair you
can't do that you know but I gotta tell
you if you went to somebody and said
here's what we'll do we're gonna give
you 1500 1500 bucks cash per month sound
good but yeah but don't vote like that's
that's the deal they'll they'll say yes
I don't care sure no everybody I know
where I grew up and say yeah yeah they
don't vote like that anyway
but then think about ballot harvesting
yeah these people who don't actually
care all that much have someone come and
say fill that out no sure fine whatever
and then they they get that vote and
that person normally would not have gone
to vote so my my view of this is you're
not going to solve the problem uh
there's a Starship Troopers thing
service guarantee citizenship you
familiar with that never heard of it so
it's a book it's a movie and the idea is
that in order to vote you have to
provide some service to the community so
uh you're you're a a civilian or a
citizen and uh citizens get to vote
civilians have all rights but don't vote
so then if you want to getting the right
to vote you either like join the
military or you do community service you
have to do some kind of service yeah to
contribute and that that to me makes a
lot of sense yep I don't know if I
completely agree with it in that
structure but I was thinking about like
how would you actually do something like
this how about moving forward we passed
a bill saying if you accept any
government assistance while you're on
assistance you are ineligible to vote
well it used to be sort of like that
people you had their own land or
something like that to vote uh back but
this flips it you know yeah like you
don't got to own anything you can be a
homeless guy but you're not taking from
anybody else you're not you're not
taking a hand out or anything or or
assistance the way I see it is if there
are people who are not contributing to
the system but are voting they're going
to vote to extract from the system so if
we if we all say like we're going to
hook you up because we don't want you to
suffer or anything like that but you
don't get to vote into our system and
take our stuff then I think actually
typically honest the end result of that
would be the termination of these
programs yeah because the people who
aren't on them are gonna but but to be
fair the people going on might be like
don't terminate those programs because
it's the only thing that stops these
people from destroying everything I
think a lot of these programs need to be
reduced anyway like the snap program is
supposed to be nutritional yeah and the
number one thing people buy with food
stamps is soda chips snacks Nutter
Butters
that don't sound so nutritional my boy
look I've got poison that's literally
killing people I've gotten uh uh uh
EBT I don't think we call them food
stamps anymore whatever I've gotten that
stuff before years ago and uh it's you
you walk into a grocery store grab a
bunch of candy bars yep that's crazy to
me oh my aunt used to get 700 a month
wow yeah candy bars no she's 700 a month
in food stamps what she used to do is
she's probably watching this right now
and what she used to do is she was a
sale because you know I go my family was
middle class so middle class people they
the ones buying I mean if y'all know
that you can buy food stamps from people
my family was the one doing it you know
middle class people don't get any help
at all so she was a sale like half of it
because who needs 700 food stamps he was
a sale half of it
[Music]
that's what they do yo they're there are
people who would hang out inside of
Chicago outside of like Aldi and they'll
they'll see you go and they'll be like
hey hey let me buy it for you and just
give just give me the cash yeah and then
most people are like I don't know what
this is I don't be involved but some
people would be like uh you give me 10
bucks on top the back done yeah what
they do is they sell you so basically
they'll give you a hundred dollars you
can go to the grocery store and spend a
hundred dollars and all you have to do
is give them 50. yep and that's how
that's why a lot of people on food
that's been making money you know I'm
saying with us obviously paying taxes
less taxpayers won't get nothing from it
though see me and my me and my friends
though we were smart what we would do is
we would go to ALDI and then we would as
people were loading up the groceries we
would say can we take the cart back for
you and they go you got it and then we
get the quarter because the Aldi cart
said the quarter in it so it was like
they're like you keep you take I don't
want to walk the card back you take care
of it and keep the quarter oh snap yeah
part-time job yeah so when I was like I
was like 10 years old or whatever I was
that's how I'd buy Pokemon cards oh nice
yeah you just [ __ ] the cores and you'd
have a big thing of quarters because
people are like I don't care about the
quarter take the cart I gotta waste my
time yeah that's how I did creating jobs
that's right
there were a few times where it was
really funny where like me and my friend
are out and some guys like sure you can
bring the card back but don't forget to
give me back my quarter and then we were
like cancer
yeah uh uh I don't know where we're
going man like I was thinking about
the problem of people who vote who don't
care you know uh what do we see uh
Warnock wins in Georgia and I'm I like
does anybody really care a lot of people
are talking about Harmony Dylan she's
gonna run for RNC chair I think she'd be
way better than than you know whatever
else going on at the RNC But ultimately
I'm just like yeah yeah been there done
that dude if Republicans don't
understand what's going on with
disinterested voters voting and they're
not changing the system or adapting to
it there's no point in arguing any
policy you got all of the people I would
argue who actually know politics they
probably vote a republican yeah then
you've got the liberal types who are
either actively lying or being lied to
voting for Democrats and then you have
people who don't know don't care voting
for Democrats because of ballot
harvesting and and other things like
that and Republicans are outside of the
game I'm seeing people tweet that I
think Josh Hawley tweeted something
where he's like he's like you got to
start advocating and getting people to
vote and it's just like bro
it's valid harvesting you go to the door
you you get them to felt the thing you
get them to sign off as your caregiver
in the states where it's legal and then
you get the votes and it doesn't matter
what the person thinks wants or
otherwise they don't know they don't
care it's it's ignorant people voting so
how do we solve for that well Democrats
are never going to let you uh take away
someone just make them ineligible to
vote based on their welfare status or
whatever but that does seem like the
right way to do it it's a choice no
one's forcing you to accept the money
we're giving you money we want we don't
want you homeless and suffering we also
don't want you voting into a system
you're not contributing to I think
that's fair not only that a lot of the
reasons a lot of um
mainstream conservatives they give you
the taco points on why you know the
midterms didn't go how people want it if
you actually look at the exit polls from
the midterms it doesn't it doesn't have
that view uh Republicans actually gained
in every single voter group except for
homosexuals and um and unmarried women
those are the only two voter groups out
of every single one they flip they flip
unmarried men they flip married women uh
we gained in the 18 to 29 crowd uh but
we we didn't gain those too but you know
Republicans aren't smart because culture
is obviously I think about the host
politics I don't think it even matters
who the politicians correct because
we're operating out of hate no one cares
to listen to anybody else if they're on
the supposed their political enemy
that's why we need president yay it's
raw power
like I think an outsider has to come in
and destroy the system I don't know
about yay though
well I make a case for it on in the in
the white I let him make a case for it
and uh but I think an outsider is needed
like I I watch after Trump's speech
it was so boring he was so boring and uh
you know like when he started talking
about executing drug dealers and stuff
like I'm like I don't need another War
on Drugs I would argue that social media
is more powerful than politicians
especially uh yielding uh yielding power
yeah uh but uh are you starting the
first uh juice for yay uh campus it's
actually Jews for Jesus yeah Jesus
that's kind of a blasting you know
what's funny if people paid attention to
the culture the Republican party will
have a much better time but they're so
stupid if if you really watch when Trump
said he was running announced he was
running if you go look at all the
hip-hop laws and stuff like that the
comment section was I'm definitely
voting Trump oh yeah as soon as he said
that that that that drug in the comment
go right back to them same comments they
said dang he lost my vote in three
minutes to me it seemed like watching an
old band do Greatest Hits like Mick
Jagger getting trotted down and said
well Mick Jagger has more energy than
that but yeah I was just like
after that politician just doesn't
politicians don't matter anymore I'm
still waiting for the rally to still be
lit though yeah it's it's just raw power
yeah all it is right now there's no laws
there's no Norms it's just the excess of
power and what people are willing to
accept
I was talking about this a few years ago
and the next stage in this is the um
disillusion of confidence in government
or I don't know if there's a better way
to say it but I think one potential
thing that could happen moving forward
is already with the midterm elections
you've got people now claiming fraud and
a bunch of other things they don't
respect it it doesn't matter Katie Hobbs
certifies her own election and people
are just coming out right being like I
reject that like she certified her own
election yeah it doesn't matter it's
it's the raw exercise of power so then
what I fear we head to this point where
Joe Biden's gonna say something he you
know Joe Biden's the favorite to win
right now 2024 on predicted yep Trump
dropped off Rhonda Santos is up a little
bit but Biden is above DeSantis to win
of course it doesn't mean anything you
know it's just it what it means is
people feel like he's likely to win yeah
win call it whatever you want if Joe
Biden quote unquote wins if Donald Trump
wins it doesn't matter who wins in 2024
half the country will say no half the
country will say yes what I see
happening is if Biden wins I wouldn't be
surprised if you see in small towns
a handful of of local guys with rifles
setting up barricades on roads and
saying you know this is our checkpoint
now we're keeping our community safe
you'll get the federal law enforcement
pulling up being like hey clear this out
and they'll be like we don't recognize
you based that's that's all but we I
mean you look at what happened with the
Bundy stuff this stuff has been bubbling
up for a long time yeah I've been
reading about I've been reading a lot
about the Civil War and and watching
documentaries and stuff there was talk
of a Civil War in 1820 because of what
was going on in this country and then it
took 40 years for it to actually pop off
so people people right now when you see
the fact that the FBI is is look I'll
put it this way we know the FBI does the
things they do right but now it is out
in the open and they're failing at it
they have lost that that level of power
and the confidence in them is gone
when when people start now calling them
illegitimate and calling for their
abolition give that 10 20 years
especially with antifa we get to the
point where antifa in 20 years these
people are older and they have kids who
are antifa and some right-wing dude's
going to come out and be like we got to
get rid of the FBI and they're gonna go
yes
and then what's the FBI going to do
what's the federal government going to
do so I just sort of like that right
considers are calling for the
three-letter government agencies to be
uh done with and antifa is doing the
same thing people actually talk to a lot
of antifa members they they are
anti-government they don't even like
regular liberals uh they hate me and I
hate them obviously they put me on a Hit
List man I can't I can't rock what did
they say liberals get the what two
they spray painted on a wall in um in uh
where was it Berkeley I think it was was
it a Berkeley yep they a threat against
liberals so put it that way Mass
surprise far left as they put a sickle
and a hammer or whatever yeah yeah of
course man but uh if if we're if we're
seeing
the U.S intelligence agency's plans all
just being exposed
Emperor's got no clothes regular people
you're not convincing them anymore so
how long do you guys think it will be
until people are just like
I don't think they have any Authority
10 years 10 years I think it could be 10
years
a lot of information is coming out
fairly quickly Now it only takes us for
a few a few right or wrong things
however you view it to happen four years
you say four yeah
two years and after the next election
let me let me let me ask you man
I love I love the the time travel test
if you went back in time of 2015 and
explained even one-tenth of what
happened in the past couple of years
somebody would they believe you correct
so so so go to someone and just be like
look here's what happened okay so you
know we have after the whole country
locked down because of the pandemic and
businesses were shut down there was a
widespread riding and then of course you
know people were mad at Donald Trump who
was president at the time and then after
he failed to secure his his re-election
we end up with a bunch of uh Trump
supporters uh storming into the capital
people are like hold the hold on slow
down slow down there's a pandemic yeah
well well you know depending on who you
ask uh okay Donald Trump was President
Donald Trump was President yeah yeah
people stormed the capital yeah yeah and
a bunch of far leftists through fire
bombs at a church no one's going to
believe you they just it sounds so when
when I say
four years it's because of the strassau
generational Theory that they I guess
the we're in the fourth turning this is
a whole you know generation of chaos or
whatever and then uh 2028 is supposed to
be the the
when they calculate the the years 2028
should be basically the end of the
fourth term I'm running for president in
2028 but that means something Good's
about to happen get it oh true facts
then lead Back to the Future so that
means 2026 is when the darkest point
hits and then the culmination is 2028
when we start to pull out of the mess
I agree I agree Bryson 2028 ladies and
gentlemen you actually going to run for
president yeah I mean I dropped a song
called Braxton 2028 so I gotta do it now
that counts as like a legal declaration
or something it isn't a legal
declaration it's a song
it's hard
we have Bryson 2028 merch though to
prepare us all
but I'm thinking about it let me say
that on your show I'm thinking about it
if you were to go uh let's let's go back
and go back in time to 2016 2018 and
tell the average person that uh in a few
years the FBI will have been will be
exposed as violating the First Amendment
outright by by having direct access to
sensor content on Facebook and Twitter
and I would imagine YouTube You Know
YouTube wasn't mentioned in these
lawsuits or anything Facebook and
Twitter were if you went and told people
that they'd probably just say what
conspiracy there's conspiracy theorists
how about this I got a better one for
you if you went back 10 years and said
uh no you go back seven years and you go
to yourself and say in seven years it
will be exposed that there was a cabal
of powerful Global Elites trafficking
children to an island they'd say shut up
I used to watch Alex Jones so I would
have been like yes
I'm on five and seeing Kanye West at the
time telling uh everyone that George
Bush doesn't care about black people and
now you tell them what kind oh yeah he
is saying right now will they would they
believe it to be fair in 2018 TMZ did an
article and basically told people that
that yay was saying the things that he's
saying now and nobody just no but that
was that was just four years ago oh that
was four years ago yeah
yeah I mean take anything that's
happened in the past couple of years and
then apply it to 10 years ago and people
would call you a psychopath yeah the
illusion is gone even the narrative is
broken even with genders and stuff like
that oh yeah I used to write blogs about
this when the LGBT started boycon
Chick-fil-A because the Dude opposed
same-sex marriage and I if you would
have told me that people would have been
walking around claiming to be like weird
genders out of like okay I believe
something crazy gonna happen but shut up
we got to do a skit for like cast castle
where it's like you know Luke goes back
in time 10 years and then he's like I
gotta warn them and he's like there's
gonna be 50 genders there's gonna be
children getting stuck exchange
operation dog politicians and dog masks
literally retired retired army wearing
dog face masks Donald Trump's the
president and and his supporters are
going to take over the Capitol Building
they're like okay lock this guy up no no
I'm telling you the truth yeah that
would have sounded crazy in like 2014.
there's no prisons in the future yeah
yeah
you could wear masks and people like it
when you do they're shoving things up
their butts because they think they have
a respiratory illness all right grandpa
come on get in the truck gotta bring you
somewhere for your medication oh yo
we're here though
like it's not a joke this isn't a skit
and now we're really living in this
right now it's funny because I'm like it
would be a skit to say the things that
are literally happening are happening
now imagine what's going to happen 10
years from now it's going to be the next
thing what's going to be the latest
thing I'm just imagining like people are
gonna be walking around in shark
costumes and like restaurants like
you'll go into a Starbucks and give them
coffee and they'll give you money
everything's going to be backwards and
broken South Park uh unicycle machine
with the insertable things I think
that's going to come to life 10 years I
see people arguing for like citizenship
for robots oh that's gonna happen oh
they're gonna say these robots marry
them you know all that stuff yeah cash
will be done because an airport it's
hard to find an airport where you can
actually use cash now right true yep
yeah so no it looks it looks beautiful
out there
well here's the thing about the AI stuff
you know if you watch like Star Trek
they have that episode what's it called
The Measure of a Man where they're
trying to determine whether data the
Android is a sentient life form they
like to have a trial for it the issue is
networking exists there's not going to
be AI there's going to be an AI
like true when you when you pull up chat
GPT this like AI chat program
it's got the Consciousness amalgam of
like a billion people all these
different ideas from the internet all
just compressed into one
so it's like an omni being
kind of like if you guys I don't know if
you guys have played uh Horizon
um what's the what's the new one
forbidden West there's Horizon zero Dawn
part two is for Ben West long story
short spoiler alert everybody because
the game is not that old but spoiler
there's a earth gets wiped out long
story short um stop replicating robots
destroy the planet and in the first game
they're like we're gonna build big
factories underground so after the
machines wipe all organic life out and
then shut down from a lack of fuel we
restart and terraform the planet and
bring life back there's another group of
people who are like we're gonna fly off
in a spaceship and leave Earth and go
colonize somewhere else those people
eventually combine their Consciousness
into an AI realize how dangerous that
was and try and destroy it but the AI
overpowers them and then chases them off
as they flee and tries to destroy them
so it's interesting to like see that
game granted it's just an artist from
today who had an idea in the implemented
idea but when I look at these AI
programs that's basically what it is
it's the the the the idea of every
person who ever wrote an article online
every social media post has all been
combined to one thing yeah that's creepy
that's how I feel I don't I'm not really
into AI art like I think it lacks any
urgency that a human would have given
real art
um and that's kind of how you're
describing it when I look at air it's
just like a a collage of everything on
the internet art is uniquely human right
exactly it has to be art has to be
uniquely human a robot can't make a song
well never mind yeah
I think though the scary thing is they
have created AI programs where you can
load in you you can tell it to like make
me a pop song and then the crazy thing
about it is the words are not real words
yeah like you'll hear a song it'll be
like
but then you'll hear like instead of
singing you'll hear just you guys ever
hear Prince and that song Prince and
Colin and chisel um
it's like this Italian guy from the 70s
singing gibberish that's meant to sound
like English yes this is what the AIS
make because they don't actually speak
English so it's like a person singing
like bhaga doba sharbargo and it's like
it's nothing is it on key yeah yeah yeah
but yeah but here because it's like have
you ever looked at a spectral analysis
of a song yeah a computer can see that
and just know all the data instantly and
then look at patterns of 10 000 songs
and it can track all the songs by chart
ranking you can take a song that never
charted to a song that charted a billion
and the computer will be like here's
what is commonly occurring in top
charting songs and not non-charting
songs and you can choose where on the
chart I want this to be a top 40. I want
this to be a top 100 I want to be a
number one here's the crazy thing when
the when the vocals come in and it's
singing gibberish you just cut that out
and then sing English over it in the
melody the computer wrote and you've got
AI generated it makes the beat
everything I gotta see this ain't no way
no AI into a hard beat bro they've
already got could though that's the
thing so I like because they could take
all the trap songs out there and like
there's hundreds of thousands and then
turn that into something that there's
already a web service that has a whole
bunch of it probably has like thousands
of Beats thousands of Melodies and the
the the the AI can change the the uh the
pitch or whatever you there's a program
I forgot it's called there's a bunch of
them actually you log in you put give me
a hip-hop song and then it will
automatically just string together a
whole bunch of Beats based on like
parameters this beat can can interchange
with these beats and then it'll
automatically generate the song for you
but no no vocals
that's that's currently available right
now for like 50 bucks
yep what bro you can go in and be like
make me a three you can tell that you
can say the duration the tempo the style
and it will make you the song and this
what I'm talking about is very
rudimentary basically you spend like 50
bucks a month and you get the service
but once it generates a song for you you
just give it to your engineer and say
that's the demo yeah give me the give me
the studio version okay but they
actually do have AIS that can make a
full studio production with strings bass
guitar drums everything and gibberish
yes like you have the rights after yep
you better become a producer when I get
my Ubi and I don't vote anymore
you can't sell the song that was
generated from the AI you can sell the
version that you've adapted like an
interpolation or whatever right you
still gotta like mix it down and
everything like that and combine
everything in a professional manner
right but it gave you a draft exactly a
demo yeah so but but there was a video I
watched years ago of them making an AI
generated song there's a whole bunch of
them actually someone did a video where
they're like I told I put Comfort and
Sons into an AI and said make me a new
song and it's like on Eurovision man
they had a track on Eurovision a while
ago there was a song that was up for
running for the track of I think I
forget what it was but it was in
Eurovision when they were doing their
track of the year the AI probably let's
be honest here probably already took
over everything and is in charge of our
society especially when it comes to the
algorithms determining what people see
what they think what what they could be
able to actually visualize uh there's an
interesting article by the New York Post
that I think is worth pulling up that's
titled Capital Records uh uh
Cuts ties with virtual rapper after
n-word controversy so there's already
virtual rappers there's also
conversations about virtual influencers
uh there's already artificial
intelligence writing uh articles for
major websites so so the AI is here and
it already took over a lot
yeah that's right yeah right I don't
know I don't think people that would
accept
uh uh a.m music artists because people
people like to be fans of of people but
then like think of the the gorillas and
people go and see a band yeah but
they're still artists though I know I
know but like they're still seeing like
an avatar live right and that is like
the next level I'm sure there's kids out
there who would do it isn't that why he
got in trouble though it's because like
the guy that was actually making it was
like a white guy and he was using the
n-word and they're like whoa oh I didn't
know
but this is an AI rapper but the person
who made the algorithm right I think so
but the person in the algorithm like I
forget what the situation was but I'm
pretty sure that was the reason they
canceled him or like they canceled yeah
he was signed and then immediately so so
the AI rapper already had his first
controversy yeah he got canceled I
already got canceled the next mixtape
was hard
oh man yeah what timeline are we living
in bro I got a timeline for you from our
good friends over at clown world did we
talk about this one yet guy with mask
got mad because some guy walks too close
to him without wearing a mask yes this
is uh This Is Where We Are
turn the volume down
[Music]
you're gonna go to jail look at these
people with the masks on right
so so hold on just like consider this
this guy is mad that some guy was close
and without a mask on so he wants to get
closer to him yeah it's always the
tightest mask too with these people and
they get so mad maybe it's the pressure
you know the pressure and it's causing
their head to yeah no serious question
though with stuff like this
what happened to people's brains now
hold on did they never have one or did
something break it they were easily they
were fragile to begin with
I think a lot of these people I think
hope it broke people's brains bro what
do you think will happen if you're happy
with stuck inside of houses for two
years straight and having a fear you
know what I'm saying like like what you
know something's on something has to
mentally happen there because I'm in a
disco with a lot of people including
liberals and Liberals are really crazy
this dude said he literally the furthest
he went out of his house was his
backyard for two years straight and I
said
Howard Stern said he didn't leave his
house for like two years what because he
was afraid to do so yeah and just a
couple weeks ago he did to have dinner
with some friends that's right and other
otherwise he was too scared to go
outside that's not even good for your
immune system it's horrible for it yeah
there's people talking about super flues
and and super bacterial infections
because people's immune system is isn't
up to shape like it like it should have
been with normal human conflict what
happened to these people no no for real
cause like Howard Stern was a crazy guy
back in the day now he's hiding in his
basement for two years yeah did
something happen to their brains I think
if they know what well you fear they can
control you and these people bought into
the fear of kovid my theory is that a
lot of smart people understand that the
gut and brain are related so they first
launched a bigger attack when it came to
destroying our food which destroyed our
gut with our gut being destroyed
therefore people's brains are destroyed
and uh I think people take advantage of
that situation I think it was a
deliberate move I think it was a
conspiracy that was orchestrated by some
very powerful individuals that pulled
off the larger uh destruction of
people's mental health and what better
way to of course control someone than to
of course destroy their cognitive
ability to think for themselves to think
strongly to be independent than to of
course be emotionally weak and uh easily
controlled half fructose corn syrup all
the soil seed oils seed oil the food
pyramid all the chemicals that they put
in there uh chemicals that they keep
changing in the name of so people don't
find it uh so I think I think you know a
lot of this was orchestrated top down I
don't think it's an accident I don't
think it was incentivized because of
profit there are some layers to it where
some people are incentivized by by uh by
the money especially when it comes to
using corn and soy which is subsidized
by the government but I think the bigger
reason why it's subsidized is because of
these larger control efforts which by in
part come along with the larger distrib
attribution of it I agree they how many
simulations did they run of this type of
thing before we got what we got but
that's obviously like I think a top-down
thing but then when you think of these
people I had so many friends who I
thought I grew up we were punk rock
anti-establishment and they just bought
into the establishment yeah so hard I
was I was dizzy at first I thought I was
crazy because I was surrounded by so
many people who really bought it people
literally are starting to have panic
attacks out of nowhere they're driving
their car and they start freaking out
now if you have someone who's not in
control of their nervous system or their
immune system if you have someone
already on the verge of freaking out you
just add a couple ingredients to that
you add the fear monitoring you add the
videos from China of people just falling
down and collapsing you add politicians
telling you to go to Chinatown you're
creating a recipe for disaster and and I
think you know a lot of this is more
planned than we we even give it credit
to because if you look at every step of
the way it's almost as if everything was
engineered from the very start to get us
in into this mess I was at Blaze Studios
a couple years back and uh Glenn back
with the studio they got these old
newspapers on the walls
and as I'm waiting I'm reading one of
them and it was a story from like 1800s
where some dude walked out of a bar and
he's like chilling and then some other
guy walks out and just puts a gun to his
chest and shoots him
and it was like a crazy story and I'm
like man was that what it was like back
then just like you're hanging out at a
bar and then someone randomly shoots you
and then I paused and thought for a
second and I was like that's literally
what it was like growing up in Chicago
so maybe maybe maybe actually wasn't
that crazy back then and people actually
just do crazy stuff but then I started
thinking about how a lot of these people
like Howard Stern are terrified of death
and I was thinking about how back then a
lot of people weren't maybe I don't know
we're so comfortable we're so gluttonous
we're so safe that we just are genuinely
terrified of injury or death whereas
back in the day people were like you
might die well people also don't have
God and they don't have a bigger
connection
that's the spirit and the soul but and
and I think you know a Godless Society
is also leading to individuals not
having a better understanding of of our
existence and this is for leaving that
that emptiness is being filled with
corporations so let me ask you Bryson
and maybe maybe what's happening the
reason these people are so terrified of
covid is because their view is this is
all I am and all I ever will be and more
spiritual more philosophical and more
religious people are kind of like I'm
not super worried about it like you know
the world is the way it is and there's
something waiting for me afterwards so
when you have God you have to think
about it life is bigger than you so your
your self is not the main thing in in
Western societies mainly the me me me me
me culture is why everything is becoming
more Galaxy everybody is solely caring
about themselves so of course you're
going to fear death if you think this is
the end-all be y'all and you you don't
have God there's nothing bigger than you
to think about so you are your God at
that point everybody's gonna have a God
whether you like it or not and a lot of
people God is them is themselves so I
think that's the issue in uh in our
society and I think it's plaguing
Western societies period I think it's a
materialism problem yep right if you
don't have God you start to worship the
things you have to yeah we meet it we
humans we need something like that to be
in front of us we need we we sort of are
hardwired to have some type of Idols
that's why everybody had leaders every
tribe has a leader you can go find a
random tribe in in the jungle right now
I bet you it's going to be a leader you
know what I'm saying she is but if
you're in charge right and you have a
lot of power what better way than to
kind of bamboozle everyone from
worshiping something spiritual something
deeper being there from their family
members what better way than to convince
them to worship their Disney stars or
their celebrities or they're politicians
that are literally created in in in in
these effigies in these candles in these
in these dolls where right now we have
fouchy candles we have Andrew Como
candles they have replaced normal
religion with the religion of the state
the religion of of the cult which is
essentially a corporatist banking agenda
that is destroying people of any kind of
spiritual deeper existence and uh pretty
much uh exchanging it with obedience to
the state we need Jesus everybody needs
Jesus the state should discuss everybody
and this is one of the things I pressed
with yay because he was like he's
looking for advice everywhere even like
with you in here like he's asking people
questions and I'm like all right one
thing I've heard you do is like
sometimes you just say the word Tuskegee
and we don't talk about it but like if
you actually expand on that to a large
audience you will start to show people
why they should fear this government
because they will do terrible things to
you always and forever and because we
just like keep a blind eye to it I'm
like and that's just one example of of
many things that this government has
done to his own people and we don't even
know the worst of it right yeah imagine
how bad it gets about the stuff we still
don't even know about I mean we found
out about about the island and and the
children that were sent there for
politicians to do whatever they wanted
to do with lots of them also missing
that's that's what we know that that's
only one percent of what we know yeah
like go go look up after the show
everybody what what America did for and
the Steve Unit 731 in Japan oh yeah yeah
if you want to feel disgusting unit unit
uh was it seven seven three one yeah
they would take prisoners and then stick
their arms through a hole into Sub-Zero
temperatures to freeze while still
attaching their body right and then they
would pull it in and shatter the arm to
see what would happen correct wow yes
there was babies born in captivity and
they would do things to them they would
they would vivisec people and have them
eat their own organs we all been to CIA
still influences journalism you know
they said they they said they stopped it
though in court yeah oh then it must be
they're very trustworthy you can always
trust those guys it's not like they ever
lied before I got one for you I got one
for you go back in time 20 years and go
to a CIA IA or FBI agent in telum 20
years from now
people in this country will have their
own shows that they start and launch
to the tune of millions of people
watching every night
and they will be able to expose
everything that is you're doing
would they believe you no they
controlled everything
but but I'll tell you this if you ever
do go back in time don't warn them
yeah we like this right
we want to be able to you know call them
out that's why I think it's like a
tremendous white pill you know the fact
that we get to make fun of these guys
who like he's wearing a mask and he's
freaking out and he's screaming at some
other guy the fact that they can be the
subject of ridicule it'll change things
the fact that the FBI isn't able to get
away with a lot of the stuff they're
doing it'll change things I mean the
changes are happening all around us
that's why the internet is so
bittersweet it's sweet because we we do
have access we have access to
information and we can you know Freedom
of Information that however much you
think that tell us and we can get on
here and expose people to everybody's
platforms but at the same time the
internet is so toxic too it's like a big
high school do you think the pros
outweigh the cons
no yeah I I don't know I go back and
forth because it's like it's all
connecting and like all the things we
got to share the disinformation the past
two years and you know what maybe yes
because if everything was still
controlled somebody as crazy as me would
not have like a Billboard Chart and song
like come on bro right here you get to
share music and all of our art and we
get to talk freely for the most part
even on sometimes but like I want to be
a t-shirt vendor exactly so true see
look at all the positivity we're
creating okay maybe even I will even
maybe even I'll go with that because
there are horrible things that it does
too there's another thing about it
people have to have access like let's
talk women for example they had to have
access to like magazines to understand
what the beauty standards were not just
go on Instagram and everybody's trying
to look like Whoever has 10 million
followers you know everybody want to be
Kylie Jenner or Kim Kardashian the same
exact person yeah almost identical yeah
almost every last one those are clones
yeah clones fake books for sure Botox
yeah fake lips looks like they got
punches in the mouth have you seen the
girls with a super long nails okay I'm
just going off yeah
now we're hitting the good issues yeah I
was talking about it earlier man there's
no purpose
people have no no goal they have no plan
they don't know what they're alive for
Washington Post put up this article
saying that like young people are
suffering from extreme levels of
depression like not seen before yeah
because they got nothing to live for
they're Wayward
look back in the day people had religion
Faith got right
today a lot of people still do but uh 20
30 years ago people had their Community
they had their classes they had their
state you know uh state championships or
whatever they'd go and they'd watch the
community and cheer them on there was
something they focused on there was
something they were working for today
they have nothing yeah so what do they
do they go on Instagram and they say
what will get me social satisfaction I
need more likes what gets me more likes
garbage yeah bazungus garbage generic
content booty shaking and then what
happens when you don't get the likes
anymore
like people's people's psyches are just
shattered think about this right you can
go to the poorest country in Africa take
your pick
and I bet you the United States of
America has a higher rate of depression
agreed yeah yeah I would also say
um you said people need Jesus yeah
that's one way to put it I would simply
put it this way people with Jesus are
doing better than people without facts
that this is not me making a religious
statement what I'm saying is the people
who have no faith and no plan have have
higher rates of mental illness have
higher rates of depression
and the people who have religion have
something anchoring them
it's bigger than us we don't when you
truly you know in the word of God are
usually trying to live a different
lifestyle uh I mean you don't really
have time to be depressed you know we
start changing your life for god like
people don't understand I have never
been depressed in my life and I've been
celibate 13 years almost because I'm
waiting for marriage you know what I'm
saying I don't get drunk I've never
tried any drug period I've never been on
pills or anything and I am like so happy
that's why people think people think
like right just don't care about
anything why who cares bro I just say
what I want and in my in my mind I have
the armor of God on and it's about God
so you know what they say misery loves
company right so when when uh the left
started mocking Ben Shapiro because he
was a virgin until he got married they
were like haha look at him look at he's
a virgin and he was like and then
they're like haha we're making fun of
you and he was like this is something I
wanted like what are you talking about
but they want to drag you into their
world where they have higher rates of
depression higher rates of architecture
drug addiction alcohol no families yep
yo I was I was uh uh I was talking to
some friends man
and I think everybody's probably had
this conversation probably a bunch of
other shows have had the conversation
more than we did I got a question for
everybody
these single white liberal women who are
in their mid to late 30s Milano's like
I'm 36 I'm gonna be 37 soon 31. these
these what do they call them affluent
white female liberals cat women they
have no kids what are they going to do
when they're 60 70 years old they have
no family to take care of them when they
can no longer work what are they going
to do
they're gonna be depressed they're gonna
have a lot of cats we're already saying
it I mean and they're going to be on a
lot of drugs how are they going to get
those drugs big Pharma how are they
going how why would you're saying big
farm is going to be like lady here's
some free drugs no no they're gonna of
course uh yeah have only fans that can
afford it
for like 50 60 year old only
real some 70 year olds may find an
audience but overwhelmingly it's not
going to happen true so my question is
how will they get those drugs
live I don't know
Ubi maybe they're gonna vote for what
they're going to vote for oh they're
going to vote Democrat regardless people
who don't have families yeah to support
them will vote for the state the state
correct yeah they are communism baby
yeah that's true they already do
atheists single single atheist people
obviously mostly vote Democrat but
single single women unmarried women
they're big voter blocks they were very
significant for these midterms as well
they made a major difference yeah if you
look at from the 2018 midterms to this
mid terms we didn't gain at all with
unmarried women
it's not just about the women though
it's it's about the men as well
but you know I'm just wondering seeing
all of these people who are not having
families and are advocating for not
having families right when they're in
their 70s in their retirement age
there's going to be an elderly antifa
riots demanding more money yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's all I have too there's
going to be a lot of broken hips
I'm trying to have 10 kids trying to
have a football seven football I win a
basketball team I've been saying that
for years
to Luke I mean why not right you better
get started I'm working on it yeah I
gotta get started too yeah yeah it's
it's crazy out there yeah crazy world
man then you gotta Shield those kids
against the reality and that's that's
the they will be like little Jedis like
everyone that comes into my life I teach
them how to shoot I teach them how to
defend themselves I teach them a
hand-to-hand combat uh I don't care if
you're a woman I don't care if you're a
friend I keep motivating everyone here
like let's do the kickboxing let's kick
some butt that's great uh so I mean
that's just me around me my kids are
going to be around that so they're going
to be raised to know how to handle a
firearm as well my kid's gonna be
menaces I can tell you that right now
people think I'm bad
I'd say homeschool your kids yes keep
them away from this uh woke degeneracy
and stuff like that yes it's scary out
there but there's more than just that
there's the how you know you're getting
good sound medical advice you got to
find a good doctor especially those kids
growing up you got to make sure you're
getting real food you're not going to
pump their brains full of fluoride I
love how they have the nursery water
with extra fluoride in it but then you
can simply Google search and it's like
there's there's recommendation from
um pediatric doctors and stuff like
don't give your babies Florida why do
they sell that at the grocery store oh
yeah we interviewed doctor after doctor
till we found like the right place when
we moved down here because you can't
trust doctor we got kicked out of
practices for not doing certain things
they wanted us to do when they want us
to do it in New York when we're still
there well it's it's simple you you go
to a doctor you ask them basic questions
about your health and if they can't
answer basic questions then you need to
find a good doctor yeah and a lot of
doctors these days I feel like I just go
there and and they hardly look at me
they're just looking at a computer and
checking off like check marks they just
throw pills at you yeah I'm like I
didn't come here for this yeah anyway
women that's why you know they they
always recommend anything that's wrong
with a woman they always tell them birth
control right yeah
[Music]
so like some doctors that will be honest
with you and give you like holistic
doctors or you have to go to like some
natural doctors but most of these
mainstream daughters that they're just
throwing the worst thing at you they'll
do it for everything like depression
everything skin everything anything they
possibly birth control has so many
negative side effects so many things
that mess up mess up your thyroid mess
up your whole reproductive system uh it
is absolutely one of the most
destructive medicines out there that
people aren't warned they're they aren't
told hey this is going to create
long-term damages or it could even lead
to you having the wrong partner since
your your pheromones and your smells are
going to be off yeah and then once
you're off of them you're gonna not be
attracted to the person you're with so
it's just crazy but that's what the
experts are telling them though we're in
like a failure of experts my last doctor
in New York I I get anxiety real bad
throughout you know whatever uh and my
last time I had real bad anxiety I went
to the doctor I'm looking to see what we
could do so I'm hoping I would hear like
we gotta work on that diet and you know
eat better get some exercise she
literally told me to get the the vaccine
and I was like like why she was like
will it help with your fear I'm like
well I don't have fear of that my
anxiety is like with like money kids you
know life stuff like that and uh that's
what that was her first response what I
never saw her again I was like I'm out
well I would have told her off I would
have been like well are you crazy
what are you doing here I was so shocked
I just left I was like I can't believe
it was real what's the right answer like
therapy the doctor's saying like I
recommend you sit down with a therapist
that would be better yeah you know but
like honestly I thought we were gonna
have like a talk I I wanted to have my
heart looked at I I I'm crazy sometimes
I'm like maybe something's wrong
cardiogram that was her that's how she
came to me yeah if someone's dealing
with anxiety you're like okay what are
you eating how's your sleep are you
exercising right uh how is your gut
let's do a gut test let's see let's
let's do a full test on your your you
know levels of of uh you know hormones
in your body Let's test it out let's see
if this is an imbalance let's see if
this is just mental let's let's figure
out let's diagnose the problem look I'm
I'm not a doctor so make sure sure you
talk to a doctor about what's right for
you but I just I feel like whenever I
meet someone and they say something like
I'm suffering from these conditions the
first thing I think is what are you
eating yeah oh it's so true is it yeah
and I feel like a lot of these people
like there was a commercial I was
watching and it's like suffering from
heartburn and it's just a guy going like
and it's like take this pill and then
because I'm eating pizza and I'm like
dude if you're eating the pizza and it's
screwing you up stop eating the pizza
man no but no we could just take a pill
and it's gonna be fine do you drink a
lot of coffee yes do you drink it first
thing in the morning without anything uh
yes okay stop doing that okay so you are
my doctor stop doing that that's what I
do every day for breakfast yeah and he's
fine I'm it's my brain I don't know
we'll have a private talk later I talk
about this all the time I've been
looking at the studies I I literally uh
do this on my own like members area
where I diagnose and I go into the
studies and I talk about this but that's
but that's one thing but I love having
these conversations especially with like
Dr Drew when he was here uh but but stop
doing that immediately we'll talk later
taking a pause
yeah not medical advice I'm not a
medical doctor not here giving you
however medical advice uh but uh we'll
talk privately because I don't want to
get into two more of yourself every day
I wake up
and uh recently I've been doing brewed
coffee like like you know your typical
ground Brew I usually do cold brew I
love cold brew it tastes so much better
yeah and uh I'll do uh heavy cream and
coffee and that's what I have and then
for a while I talked about this I was
doing eggs and bacon but recently I just
been not having breakfast so I just just
straight coffee with coffee and cream
that's it I never had coffee in my life
I've ever tried it wow what never tried
coffee why
I'm a super taster yeah so I probably
couldn't I probably wouldn't be able to
handle coffee how do you know you're a
super taster oh you you just yo you have
less taste buds or more taste buds
whatever I think yeah yeah more taste
sometimes have more taste buds and we're
just very sensitive like better things
so I don't eat anything spicy like
nothing spicy if chicken is too spicy I
won't eat it I eat like a chow but I
drink so much water that it is I don't
want to get into too much personal
health stuff for for you guys but
there's a reason you know someone here
has gut issues
um and the best thing to do is to at
least wait at least an hour and a half
uh because of the who has got issues uh
stress issues uh I have stomach ulcers
is that what you're talking about no oh
no I'm talking about someone else uh
we'll talk about the privately maybe
yeah someone here
um the best thing to do is start with
either kefir no I'm not I'm not talking
about myself I'm talking about someone
else here sitting here
my anxiety in my gut yeah
not even you oh no but but uh you you
should wait at least an hour and a half
uh be because of uh your hormones to
take coffee and to not feel sluggish
during the middle of the day and you
should always try to get at least uh
kefir or yogurt in your stomach before
taking something as heavy and as acidic
as coffee into your system so uh prolong
coffee use uh my own not not medical
advice this is just what I do and I've
seen uh important developments and
changes in my uh feelings and my gut
after implementing this myself it might
work for you it might not uh you might
be allergic to kefir who knows so
everybody's careful everybody's
different the best advice I give people
especially when it comes to a lot of
this stuff is is no one is no one and
nothing is exactly right for everybody
you could be allergic to something that
works for me but it could be horrible
for you so you got to do your own
homework you got to do your own research
and more than ever you have to be
vigilant more than ever obesity rates
are going up out our calorie intake
hasn't changed what's going on here
something is corrupt something's really
horrible something really nefarious is
happening right now with People's Health
being deliberately destroyed you got to
be on top of it more than ever that's
what I do for myself and we could talk
and maybe even do like a little video
between me and you if you're open to it
oh yeah and I'll put it on my members
area Shaman for 10 years and gave up
Western medicine for a long time uh but
like I I uh I've done the thing for a
while and I had I did see differences
where I would wake up and just drink um
warm water with lemon and nothing else
Ginger is pretty good too oh Ginger too
mastic gum is also a really good uh
colostrum is also really good especially
if you have gut issues but again again
you could be allergic to those things
and do your own homework and it might
hurt you depending on your gut levels I
cut out a lot of most carbs years ago
and lost like 40 or 50 pounds yeah uh
and that my brain just got different I
slept better thought better I was way
better at everything this is this is it
bro you know a year ago I cut out carbs
and uh looking great now looking a lot
better not that you didn't before but
you lost a lot of weight yeah I lost uh
it was crazy too because I was skating
all the time I was getting like every
day but I still weighed 200 pounds and
and then one day we got covered we got
treated for it and then like a few days
later I was eating salami with cheese
and then I was like you know I didn't
need any sugar today I feel great I just
didn't eat it and people were saying
that you're gonna get keto flu from not
having any sugar I never experienced
anything yeah no no no headache nothing
just all of a sudden within like within
the first month I dropped 10 pounds and
then over the course of the next couple
of months I dropped another 20 pounds do
y'all drink coffee like every day oh I
drink coffee a lot for I got two young
kids it's hard uh I will say that like
that part makes it hard they wake up at
night I'm up super early and I'm up at
night you know right in late into the
hours but uh yeah coffee so yeah so yeah
like
no that's so interesting to me because I
don't drink anything like that but I'm
super energetic it's a part of my ritual
like when I'm I get the kids down I can
refer a nap or bring them to school and
I can make a cup of coffee and that's
how I kind of get into work mode does it
actually keep you up I heard sometimes
it can have the opposite effect I don't
think it even works on me anymore so
you're just trying to do the tradition
if you drink coffee around like if you
normally go to bed at like 11 you drink
coffee around seven you won't be
attacked you won't be tired because it
blocks The receptors I think what
melatonin or something that's right yeah
you shouldn't be taking it uh but if you
if you drink it so people who think it
wakes them up in the morning it really
doesn't caffeine does have enough uh
well I'm not gonna know everything about
caffeine but it does have very it's a
stimulant so it's it's it increases
muscle endurance it tightens your blood
vessels if you if you stop drinking
coffee you'll get migraines because it
relax it relaxes your blood vessels and
then you get a more pressure and then
your headset's the Robin and there's
also a correlation there's also a very
interesting correlation with uh our
progression as Society with the
invention of coffee and people taking
coffee becoming more productive working
a lot harder and smarter and a lot of
people attribute coffee to Modern
civilization growing as fast and as vast
as it is now I mean coffee smells good
you ever just open up fresh ground
coffee it smells terrible to me that's
why I've never tried it because of the
smell funny it's it's pretty much
illegalized cocaine I was gonna say it
sounds like cocaine it it does yeah take
a look at the effects of caffeine and
cocaine the only difference with with
caffeine it's like little bits in your
drink with cocaine it's like on the
street and in higher doses but you they
sell powdered caffeine and it is it is
crazy it has very similar uh
psychological and physiological effects
to cocaine yeah I'm good I got I got
enough energy I took some of that I'll
lose my mind this is something this
isn't really funny if you look up
caffeine powder on Amazon I don't know
if this is true but I was told that
you know Amazon does frequently bought
with it's like lidocaine and caffeine
are frequently bought together yeah so
like you do you know you know okay what
people yeah
what yeah it's like it's it's like a
it's like a yeah people are sniffing
coffee
no no caffeine powder they snippet
caffeine powder they're just I don't
know exactly what they're doing it like
I don't know I wouldn't be surprised I
recommend against it because you get
hurt wait until you learn about the
coffee enemas uh you can find out on
Luke uncensored.com
hey call me crazy do your research now
on coffee enemas be prepared to surprise
and I'll see you for that conversation
on Luke it sounds like China what is it
no no coffee animals I'm I'm dead ass
I'm being real I'm being honest here
that ass cause you're putting coffee up
your butt yes
that was the pun intended humans are
weird bro yeah for real like good all
that I am you never see like a lion
shoving coffee beans up its ass never
unless I don't know maybe you do I don't
know when I was outside your store when
I was a little kid we went on a field
trip to the zoo and we were looking at
the baboons and it was like this the
enclosure was way down and then one of
the baboons just shoved this thumb right
up his ass and then pull hold something
out and then all the kids ran over and
started screaming and hollering the
teacher was like what's going on and she
went oh get away kids get because he was
going to town I don't know what he was
doing the monkeys are weird man
that's what I'm saying you said humans
are weird I'm like I don't know monkeys
are pretty weird too my bro he knows
what they're on about it was the weird
stuff bro I'm sorry yeah well yeah I I
guess in this instance you're talking
about Luke because he's putting coffee
up his butt but you know let's read some
super chats wait wait before the Super
task Tim are you not on the yay 24 train
I'm not on the a24 train are you guys I
I don't I don't know because me I am
like a Bible thumping hardcore Christian
so when he says like the thing the thing
that irritated me about the Alex Jones
interview but the obviously the age guy
comments the only thing that irritated
me is because he said some of the most
beautiful things I've ever heard in the
interview and it got the water got
muddied because of that one comment and
people missed like the prayer he read
was so beautiful he's saying Yeshua he's
saying Yahweh I'm you're not supposed to
say Yahweh but he he's saying like the
most beautiful thing if I got overlooked
but when he says things like things to
be based on Christianity I mean that's
already how this country should be and
it's so based I love it yeah all right
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up for you at uh just about 11
p.m we usually get them uploaded so uh
that'll be up at timcast.com smash that
like button let's read some of these
super chats
all right Jay Marie says in the Soviet
Union everything that the government did
was for the sake of the party nothing
else mattered but the party anything
that would be a threat to the power
would be squashed in any manner
necessary right sounds a lot like what's
going on right now I guess yeah if
Taylor's listening this is what I was
talking about when I said the party
someone the other day with her at the
house yeah it's the party
East F says Ian yesterday you asked what
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearm had to do
with each other the ATF started out as a
branch of the IRS to collect taxes on
those items and then the Tyranny
escalated from there abolished the ATF
and then someone commented the ATF
should not be abolished the ATF sounds
like the best kind of store and it
should just be the opposite of what it
is
like I gotta go to the ATF to pick up
Jake Swift says AOC they just want to
investigate me because they want to date
me Yep they're trying to get her phone
number
make ALC bartan again
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I had a
deep SC of your black pill
but important in motivating 4pms then I
saw the fun chefs uncensored be honest
to use a stick of butter on bacon just
to say you gotta butter the bacon
so we had Chef Andrew gruel and you know
I was talking about how I take a little
bit of butter in the pan so that the
bacon doesn't stick you know because
like you get the pan hot I'm not a chef
I don't know what's going on I just
throw bacon in the pan to get it warmed
up but then you got to move it around a
little bit because then bits of the
bacon get stuck to the pan I just put a
little bit of butter and then it doesn't
stick you know so people are saying you
know you know you don't got a butter the
bacon you got to burn the bacon man I
buttered the bacon too no but and your
girl says he doesn't put fat on fat
interesting yeah yeah but yo let me tell
you guys he told me in that members
uncensored I said I'll make like bacon
and eggs for breakfast and I'll I'll
take the eggs and I'll pour it into the
bacon grease and just you know do like a
light scramble I won't go crazy with
scramble just flip it over a little bit
he said push the eggs aside Splash a
little vinegar in the pan get that that
deglaze it get that stuff off and then
mix it into the eggs and it'll take your
eggs from a five to a ten yeah so I did
and it was incredible yeah
work alone
you don't need it that'll be poor I love
bacon why why uh parts of religious
reasons because the Bible clearly tells
you not to do it even though a lot of
modern Christians be like oh I'll eat
whatever you want but outside of that
eventually research pigs bro they're
they're animal trash cans yeah yeah yeah
literally what a pig is right is that
right the Bible says like no Bottom
Feeders and stuff like that like I think
the Bible just knew science somehow the
Bible just knew science before science
was that a double entender you like that
nice they don't have sweaters get it all
right let's read some more we got Ryan
Brown he says perhaps Shane can take a
deep dive into the rensburg prophecies
and give you all the ultimate black pill
that has been coming for over 100 years
I'll look into it you don't know what it
is I don't know what it is no I don't
all right but it seems like something
you'd know about I don't know all right
bit Pro says Elon Musk said AI is a
demon that we are trying to harness from
another portal look it up it was from
seven or eight years ago
yo that's creepy still he still wants us
to connect with it so I mean I mean he's
wearing that costume what if he came out
and he was just like well the reality is
we have to create a portal so that molok
can come through and can meld with our
minds and I'm creating technology to do
it listen Revelation 13 if people go
read it I'm not saying Elon Musk is the
answer is but if you read Revelation 13
and read Revelation 12 read the whole
book when you read it it tells you how
it's going to convince people right and
who else has that type of you know who
else has that type of power man that's
all I'm saying the SIG P says Shane
Cashman is my hero thank you I
appreciate it you're a hero
real quick in the chat everyone's asking
what kind of vinegar it's any kind of
vinegar yeah any uh he he said whatever
just a little bit a little acid to
balance it out yeah yeah white vinegar I
used uh balsamic balsamic vinegar not
too much it's got sugar in it you know
it's got like a lot of sugar in it but
it's so good yeah it changes the game so
you cook the eggs and then you put the
eggs I push them to the side I Splash a
little bit around the pan and then just
like get the the bits off the pan and
like flip the eggs around in it a little
bit and I can't describe it so I don't
have the culinary expertise to explain
it the only thing I can say is it made
it taste Fuller yeah like it's just I
don't know because he was explaining
like it's uh the way your taste buds
work or I think it was like it it it he
was using like the bitter Umami yeah
salty and uh sweet and like it
apparently like you said rounds out the
taste basically that's what he's saying
it's amazing yeah all right total
meltdown says guys have you ever seen
altered carbon that is what Elon is
trying to create a chip implanted in the
base of the skull that you implant and
to any skin have you guys seen that show
no no you can you can upload and
download your Consciousness into anybody
they travel uh uh planets not by getting
in the ship and flying out but by
uploading your Consciousness to an
existing body on the other side
yep sounds like Elon every dad's up
season one of altered carbon is really
good season two is boring altered carbon
yeah oh dang never mind I don't got
Netflix yeah
keyboard says Tim another rapper you
need to have on that wouldn't leave is
Samson great songs like 46 equals 13 The
Sixth Sense and the new song Nancy I
like Samsung Samsung school do you have
any other recommendations who else
should come on oh man we gotta we gotta
apologize we gotta issue an apology
um
Barney Boyle says zooby is a rapper Too
Tim show some respect that's right
yeah we had to be honest he's more like
an r b no no he's rap oh zombie is rap
me him got songs together
we forgot zubi when he said that so we
actually won for three and and with you
Bryce and now we're two for four so 50
50 on our rappers but uh uh Forgiato
blow Tyson James those people I talked
to like in real life on day to day uh
Bryson it's not too late
that's what's welcome to cause some kind
of controversy slap a microphone walk
out
the trigger Tim I definitely well I mean
look none of it triggered me you know
it's like
rugged Man you know he hit the
microphone we actually we hugged it out
yeah after yeah we both apologized to
each other you know I said I should I
should be me I shouldn't be saying that
stuff I shouldn't be mean I should be
disrespectful and then he apologized
similarly and then we hugged and then I
invited him come back whenever he wants
I was like if you ever feel like coming
back you know we'll have you out I
almost came in in a full like mask but I
was thinking about doing that too like
like a like a garbage bag but then I was
like where am I going to breathe yeah
yeah I can't do that all right rockslide
says Tim your vision is Destiny LMAO no
it's not Destiny um destiny for those
entertainment you guys you ever hear of
Destiny the game video game yeah yeah
there's there's there's the last City
everybody lives there The Traveler comes
and then there's like this golden age
where humans are colonizing the solar
system but then the darkness comes and
there's a collapse whatever it's like
post Halo game right I don't I don't I
don't know if it's post Halo it's it's
bungee so it's similar the problem with
it is they never gave you a sense of
accomplishment like the story doesn't
advance so I got I got tired of it but
uh that's that's I'm not talking about
that the idea of a last city with a
collapse that no one knows about is
actually a pretty common Trope you know
so not Destiny but uh and my idea was
the last City would have like comparable
technology to today because if people
were trying to rebuild a city they
wouldn't have advanced technology that
they'd be reconstructing the technology
that that they lost right I think people
forget that it's happened in history
before people had the wrong ruins and
they were in Dark Ages in Europe and
they were like oh yeah there was this
ancient civilization they had all these
huge buildings and all these uh Etc
could you imagine that yeah it's like
hundreds of years after the fall of some
major Empire and they're like did you
know that they could poop in their house
and the poop would go away yeah that's
correct Romans had indoor plumbing and
then and then after the fall of the
Roman Empire they didn't people built
houses and just took threw it out the
window right yeah they would throw it
out the window or they had these things
in castles where you would sit down and
take a dump and it would just fall all
the way yeah yep right into that moat
yep yeah
okay where are we at
Tom Wolf says Elon musk's tweet confirms
he's added staff refrigerators at
Twitter HQ but insists he's just helping
hungry employees
Bry Steinberg says the Samaritan
mentioned is like an advanced version of
the morlocks and the eloids eloids from
The Time Machine if you refuse to use it
you're cast out
I don't know I've not I've uh I've seen
the movie yeah I've not read the book
Joseph says explain to me what makes you
all think AI is possible real AI not a
stupid chat bot I think you're being
ridiculous to believe in it climate
change 2.0 so
a few years ago
we had an AI chat bot and it would say
really stupid things people thought it
was funny
today there's a chat bot that can answer
complex questions
I don't think an AI is going to be a
sentient entity necessarily I'm saying
that it'll be indistinguishable from one
and we're already getting to that point
it is just machine learning at the end
of the day but and I see your point
person who's commenting but we're just
using it as a means discussion yeah it's
going to be it's going to be dark stuff
then when they have real-time rendering
there's going to be like a screen you're
not walking to a store and then there's
gonna make a glass panel and a guy's
gonna appear and he's gonna have a
conversation you like a conversation
with you like a real person because a
computer is simulating this person have
you seen the stores I think it's like
four airports in the country it's in
Nashville airport where there's no
workers mm-hmm you haven't seen it
actually no you haven't seen if you have
a chip in your hand you can scan your
chip no cap or if you have a car you you
know you you pitch a card in before you
walk in you just walk in grab whatever
you want you walk out
wow there's no workers so I I don't
think you know AI is is some climate
change 2.0 I think if people actually
get out their house a little bit and
start traveling a little bit you'll see
how how real it is yeah like I see it
every day it's kind of I travel non-stop
but it's actually like the stuff you see
is kind of weird now bro it's so weird
yeah I mean the point I'm making with
machine learning is that like it will it
could you only do so many things when
you go to the store you're only gonna
say something hey how are you you know
whatever you can simulate that pretty
easily I think there's a little level
where we're saying like you can't
actually think complex thoughts and do
the things that humans do which is which
is true it is machine learning it's not
it's not accurate but there are so many
permutations at this point we have we're
running into the memory problem with how
much memory we can actually hold with
different conversations and stuff but it
will come eventually I think Joe Ramirez
says Ian has been educated on who he is
not allowed to criticize Tim made sure
of that because uh well I gotta tell you
Ian is on the show tonight but we do
have a Jewish man sitting in his chair
instead
[Music]
here tell them about tell them about
Jesus you know sometimes uh well
actually we got another Super Chat for
you
um maybe we could bring it bring him in
for the after show yeah based Ghost
Coast to Coast says Bryson please tell
Ian he knows nothing about Jesus
oh Ian's just sitting in his room
listening going like
yeah I would love to talk ain't about
Jesus Ian come up at 10 pm
if you're hearing that or if someone's
in the house tell Ian to to get ready
for Ted yeah true we'll have him come up
on what talk about Jesus sure well
people in the chat were asking for this
conversation at the beginning of the
broadcast so I think it would be
interesting I actually think that would
be really really great to be completely
honest but there's also a project
Veritas video
absolutely
I can't we can't even mention it here no
well we we if we were trying to not be
like if we're family friendly that's why
we can't there's a great there are great
schools and they're showing things to
children that we don't want to mention
because you may have kids in the room
yeah and passing it around and so it's
disgusting this is Criminal stuff man
well we're gonna talk about that but uh
we'll we'll get in up here as well and
then we can like I think that story is a
good segue into like discussing
godlessness
it is yeah you're the weirdest thing I
gotta say this guys I don't understand
it why I have people constantly claiming
that I'm an atheist I don't know where
that came from I haven't been an Atheist
since I was like 18. you're agnostic
more agnostic no I believe in God I
don't I don't believe in like organized
structured religion or anything like
that but I grew up Catholic was an
atheist for a couple years and as a
teenager I don't even think I really was
an atheist I just was like it was what
my peer group was saying and then I had
some conversation started researching
and now I you know and for most of my
life I've always believed in God but for
some reason there are people who are
just like well Tim's an atheist so you
know he justify I'm like yeah I am not
an atheist I am not I believe in God I
believe there is a God what's our belief
on the Bible
uh
I don't know I don't know I I don't
believe it uh I I would say on the Bible
probably more agnostic on the Bible yeah
because like uh uh I I don't like
it's it's hard to describe I won't I
don't follow it as if it's divine
scripture or a law but
I'm not the kind of person who's gonna
come out outright and be like it's not
you know what I mean well the one thing
I will say which is the most interesting
aspect of the Bible in my opinion you
look at every society in every aspect of
the world they have a story of a flood
and a specific family or specific person
being being one person that was saved
from the flood that that started new and
these are those are societies that had
no way to connect with each other they
had no way to communicate with each
other so how would they all have the
same story about a flood and I think 80
of them all have a favorite you know
person who will save during the flood
you know what I'm saying I just well you
know there's two possible explanations
right atop my head one they all come
from the same place all these people
were in the same place and then spread
out and they can't kept the stories or
everyone around the world there was a
great flood yes yes you know but I think
I think like we've we've talked about
about that there was a great flood like
I don't know if you can describe it in
like biblical terms like the way it's
being described in in science but they
were like there was a period of great
flooding or whatever yeah this is also
with like the younger driest period
everyone talks about the Sphinx has been
damaged by water people that are Joe
Rogan fans probably know more about this
than I do but that's part of this whole
Theory too I mean the other thing about
the Bibles if people actually read it a
lot of it is like such common sense that
most people would actually agree with
they just if they just sat just just sat
and read it some of it may seem a little
harsh because it's like it's ancient
it's blunt in a lot of ways my favorite
part about it but you know like the
stuff that the Bible calls wrong like it
would be kind of hard to argue even from
a singular perspective that it isn't
wrong all right that's right some more
John McGee says so if you're a disabled
veteran receiving disability you can't
vote kind of goes against your service
equal citizenship idea no I didn't say
that if you are paid benefits from the
government due to an issue that they're
responsible for you would not have the
right to vote so like if you enlist and
then you're injured the government
compensates it compensates you because
it's something you did on their behalf
yeah if you are a regular working person
living in the city and you decide I'm
going to accept free money from the
government then we say okay in exchange
you don't vote right so like if you want
to be clear then how about this Ubi for
people when they take Ubi they then
can't vote but will explicitly Define
the terms that service men and women who
receive benefits for their service will
always have the right to vote yeah
because they contributed yeah yeah did
their Duty 100 yeah I'm just saying the
people who aren't contributing right but
also again like being compensated for
liability is different from welfare you
know what I mean totally like I think I
think the government has to compensate
these these veterans because the
veterans gave something to the
government you know
yeah they did their service yeah
JJ says July 8th Shinzo Abe
assassination August 8th Mar-A-Lago raid
September 8th Queen dies October 8th the
Crimea Bridge attack November 8th FTX
crypto collapse December 8th I brought
that up before on the show uh so so
tomorrow's the eighth
yeah so what's gonna happen tomorrow all
right so your next anniversary of Pearl
Harbor you're into numeral tomorrow
I did bring together that all these
things are happening on the 8th
consecutively this year which is kind of
you know I hope it's something cool like
like Joe Biden goes in a rocket ship the
Twitter files are supposed to come out
tomorrow oh really yeah um so I still
think Joe Biden rocket ship would be
more fun what's gonna happen with
Twitter files I don't I I I'm be honest
I don't think anything's gonna come from
me I'm tired of here thinking about
people oh I hope somebody go to jail
this year no well the reason why we
haven't uh why people are saying there
wasn't a big thing that came out was
because this FBI guy was was controlling
the release of it now he's fired so he's
not controlling the release of it so now
they're gonna get the full documents as
of course Matt taibi wasn't given the
full documents before we'll see we'll
see we'll see I'm gonna tune in we shall
see It'll Get interesting man I think
it's good look it shows that the FBI's
ability to control things is gone so
watching it happen it's like it's like
funny it's like the FBI
the control they've had the games they
played completely ineffective at this
point it's exposed people can see it the
era of J era of J Edgar Hoover is over
yeah this may be the Resurgence of true
America
the will of the people do you think
certain groups will actually care
because even with the hunter Biden story
even the people that knew it was real
say huh who gives a crap yeah because
because of what side they're on well
that's that's the point about the Rocks
as a power why why look so I had this
tweet earlier it's got a bunch of
retweets and it was Rod Stewart who uh
rushed this onto the hospital who's 11
fearing a heart attack and I tweeted 11
year olds have heart attacks all the
time calm down there is nothing in the
story about anything anything else and
my point was kind of just like if
there's a story I want people to see
I will tweet something vague and
nebulous and not make a strong assertion
about it often I'll put LOL or ha or
hahaha just so that like when when you
retweet something people might ignore an
account they don't follow so it's like
you can see my commentarian is big I get
these leftists that are like Tim he
didn't have a heart attack he had a
panic attack and I was like I was it was
Matt Bender I responded I said Matt do
11 year olds frequently have heart
attacks
the answer of course is no and then all
of his leftist follows like oh Tim he
didn't have a heart attack and I'm like
the the gap between
me and you
I can't explain it to you my point was
quite literally that he didn't have a
heart attack yeah turned out he had a
panic attack
and
they think my my statement was literal
that he had a heart attack Matt was like
you need to read the article he didn't
have a heart attack and I was like God I
know 11 year olds don't have heart
attacks
you can't explain it to him and so
that's a huge problem this has been a
recurring thing the left doesn't
understand jokes yeah like a comedian
tells a joke and they're like he's
inciting violence like dude he's not
serious yeah he's they can't There's no
distinction between life and parody
anymore yeah at all yeah that happens
everything's literal for these people
the people people win woke and everybody
got so sensitive and told you what you
couldn't what you can and can't say so
they take jokes seriously yeah so that's
why we didn't go back to everybody's
getting jumped on yeah everybody black
people white people Jews everybody
everybody there should be no limits no
limits Dave Chappelle's got it right man
yeah let's rate this one we got SB says
there's a Deep Space Nine episode where
O'Brien gets captured and goes through
30 years of harsh VR prison in two hours
before being rescued he is so
traumatized he almost self-terminates
doesn't seem too far away wow there's a
movie where they invent this thing that
you put an eye drop in and it gives you
an experience so you like lay down you
put the eyedropper in and then all of a
sudden you're snowboarding an aspen and
then after the weekend is over you wake
up and it's been five minutes and you're
still in your bed and so this woman is
like working on it her partner wants to
do prison sentences without telling her
and so they take people and put the eye
drop in her eye drop in them that puts
him in like a 10-year sentence in like a
metal box
es
he just woke up
what's up bro there you go
that's why I want to tell you about
Jesus right
sorry about that
I want to know about this man Jesus
Christ there you go okay let's read some
more Super chats okay and then we'll get
into that with the members only maybe a
few questions we'll we'll uh lead us
into it right okay awesome
all right Joseph says that's such a dumb
idea Tim may be number one from you you
know I'm gonna make that TV show about
the last City and y'all are gonna be
like this is the best show I ever made
10 million episode budget's gonna be
like Game of Thrones but actually good
no not not fair Game of Thrones like the
first five seasons were legit six was
okay seven is well eight was yeah I like
the ending
we talked about this before holy I made
this argument I'm not afraid to make
unpopular opinions here okay you guys
know that you're right about the ending
uh we could talk about this later we had
full-on discussions about this when
everyone just freaked out and went crazy
on me uh well yeah because you're you're
I could make a dissertation here for 20
minutes but like no I don't want to do
that no you know as much as we don't
like the establishment narrative we have
a narrative here that we all have to
agree on otherwise you get canceled so
you know the game of dog was the best
character in Game of Thrones the dog
yeah the big dude oh yeah yeah no he was
cool though I like that guy I haven't
seen it have you guys seen Wednesday
this season is off no you haven't seen
it I'm looking at Wednesday it's it's
pretty good Wednesday
what they said they said it was racist I
was like I gotta see this guy
racism
yeah they said they're complaining that
it's racist because there's two
characters that are black who are
aggressive towards Wednesday and that's
it and they're actually good characters
they're not bad guys and they were like
why are they why are they being
displayed as having a unique character
and personality I'm outraged the story
arcs are Dynamic and it and it's
different even the villains have the
kind of understanding of why they're
villains so and Ian it wasn't the dog it
was the Hound the Hound thank you yes
that guy was awesome he's like a pal
he's like a fallen Paladin that becomes
a paladin yeah he was awesome but my
major argument which I can make for a
very long time is that it wasn't like
your Disney movie it was something out
of the ordinary it shocked people it was
different it was lazy writing obviously
but it was it it surprised you and it
wasn't the storytelling uh normal
Hollywood movie
a Lunchable sometimes I want that okay I
want I want you to have that yeah all
right Raymond g Stanley Jr says guys I
just finished Shane's yay article I'm
freaking on the edge of my seat here
gracias Shane I hope to hear more that's
just part one right yeah part two is
infinitely crazier oh man I gotta read
it I didn't expect part two I thought I
was only gonna get the the few hours I
got on Saturday and then I ended up
getting a favor what do you do he threw
you in a car and then just like slam the
gas down uh yeah well I I went to church
with yay and uh went to Bible study and
uh it was amazing it was amazing and
then yeah then I randomly I don't want
to give it all away but I will say this
I got in the car and I got to see him
rap Watch the Throne songs
he wasn't driving he had a driver but it
was a life-changing moment yeah I was
always like I never saw a concert and
then I kind of got like a one-man
concert and you were you've been a big
fan of this for a while right so much so
that when my daughter was born and the
doctor said that she was born at 808 my
wife looked at me and said you're gonna
like that aren't you
probably why I invited you out and he
knew because I kept making references to
his career and how I think he's applying
it to politics sorry right yeah I think
he could tell and it was it was a great
weekend man that must be crazy just like
you're a fan of this guy's music and
then he says I'm gonna wrap in the car
yeah and like I detest celebrity culture
I don't want to meet any celebrities
he's like literally the only person
everyone I want to meet is a dead writer
and then I got to meet him so and oddly
enough on May or no on July 23rd of this
year I post on Instagram I'm telling the
universe I'm going to interview Kanye
West this year wait you posted that when
on July 23rd what yep and just go back
and look you had no idea this would
happen at that point
what do you think his chances are for a
church for 2024 I think he could win for
even I've been saying that just because
and this is what I told him Cashman on
Instagram it's just Shane cash me this
is what I told him when I when I first
talked to him downstairs he's like
you've been rejected in every industry
you've been told no whether it's a
producer I want to be a rapper right a
rapper wants to be a pop star pop star
wants to be a designer it's always no
and then he finds a way to like take the
rejection and Skyrocket past it and make
something out of it I do think a lot of
people I was debating would be Tatum
about this on his live I think I do
think a lot of people are
underestimating uh what yeah he's doing
but not only that people have been hit
me at overly controversial was new like
literally since the big dude I've been
watching Kanye since he was just
produced Through the Wire yeah stand up
right and if you watch his old
interviews he was literally just as wild
what is this I told you Shane Cashman on
July 23rd I got it right here he wrote
telling the universe one day I will
interview Kanye West
I was listening to Jesus about to move
and I was like I just I love that record
you know and uh and I figured I'd just
post it that's some magic right there it
happened yeah wow I thought the 10
minutes I got downstairs was cool I was
on a high from that and then it turned
into uh what it turned into yo that's
nuts man yeah it was pretty wild that's
magic yeah see that's what I'm talking
about I've seen I've seen probably
thousands of things like that where
you're like come on how can that be real
life and it's things like that I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna ever claim that
because coincidence has happened I
believe in God I'm saying that there are
certain things that you see enough over
a long enough period of time you start
to question is this is there something
more is this is this is there a plan and
uh it's funny because for the secular
people they'll call it simulism yeah we
must live in a simulation and I'm like I
don't care what you call it a construct
like there's something yeah oh yeah and
that was that idea was a pressure
applied to me all weekend because I just
it just kept getting crazier and uh yeah
and then you'll see how it ends and it's
it ends in it the probably the most
wildest way it could so uh it's so cool
it was the dopest weekend
yeah
conversations about politics and his
vision and Nick's vision and like all
the things and I have questions so it's
it's not all you know just fun it's me
really trying to like make sense of
their campaign and I was taking it
seriously already and then Alex Jones
things happen and people started not
taking it seriously and I I think he
just shattered Optics right yeah any
president presidential candidate because
he's done this before it's a it's a
cyclical thing for him let's grab one
more Super chair real quick we got Kat
who says Ubi in exchange for giving up
rights to vote for your leaders said
every communist dictator ever but didn't
they do it by force and everyone yeah
wasn't it like you are given this and no
matter what you can't vote I'm saying
that there's a system where people can
choose and then you have the people who
want who who don't want the handout who
don't want the communism choose
capitalism and then vote and the people
who want communism don't get to sure
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and become a
member over at timcast.com should be
interesting we have a new a new release
from Project Veritas which is so so
shocking we don't want to say it here in
case your children are listening and I
mean that sincerely you're going to want
to see this and then we're going to talk
about uh Jesus you know Ian came up he's
got his robe he's ready to go I love
Jesus man I love the story of the guy
Moses too maybe we can talk about Moses
Muhammad yeah Moses too yeah let's do it
let's do it so smash that like button
subscribe you can follow the show at
timcast IRL follow us on Instagram for
Clips you can follow me personally at
timcast Bryson you want to shout
anything out yes uh Apple music did not
want to release my album lion music and
it's still not on Apple music but my
album live music is out you can get uh
you can get the album at
brysongreymusic.com
um and uh also Barbara Balenciaga was on
Billboard charts this week and I'm still
burning Balenciaga I might burn another
fish yeah you know what I'm saying even
though I heard because it is expensive
and if I beat Kanye maximum let me burn
his valenciaga too good luck I I rock I
rock with yay though so uh I'm sure to
be here with you you're one of the
hardest working people man it's crazy
how fast you put out the songs when
something happens but uh yeah I'm Shane
Cashman everywhere you can get the
inverted world book volume one at
invertedworldbook.com exclusively uh
season two invertedworld on timcast.com
and the brand new story with yay my part
one is at timcast.com right now check it
out front page front center that's it
this is great man thank you so much for
coming on of course I appreciate it my
website is Luke uncensored.com it's my
members area where you guys help me grow
and expand my mission and everything
that I'm doing I love to talk about
health YouTube doesn't really like that
but uh if you want to hear about coffee
enemas uh this is the place to go I want
a shout out also Liz hernberg in the
comment section she said that she cured
one of her diseases with coffee enemas
and she said quote complete complete
detox protocol you're a brave man for
vocalizing coffee enemas on this with 40
000 people watching and uh yeah I don't
I'm not here to be popular I'm here to
talk about the uh coffee enemas and
other important things Shane we're going
to fix you up Luke uncensored.com uh
thank you so much for having me Ian was
here just long enough to shout out
something yeah shout out to the people
that figure out how to make communism
and capitalism work together
James voting for people that want to opt
in maybe all right basically you get to
choose where your tax money goes on an
app all right interesting no taxes
though I am at search.com everywhere
um follow me if you'd like to Instagram
would be appreciated Twitter as well I
guess I'm using it now as much as I can
I'm still really confused by it I answer
things incorrectly like the wrong the
wrong way on the Chain I don't know
anyways astros.com that was a good one
see you guys in the after show we will
see you all over at timcast.com head
over there click that join us button and
we'll have this episode up in about
about an hour or so thanks for hanging
out and we'll see y'all there cheers